salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servez pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sfr on s'assure que la qualité
était petit mal à tous les niveaux et
puis pour ramener votre projet le haut
niveau c'est vraiment la bonne chose à
faire alors écrivez-nous savoir plaisir
de vous recevoir ici une production du f
[Musique]
bien nous en filtrent le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter date
c'est super quand je rentrais avec le
hover ait d'hommes plantes
si c'est pas encore fait assurez vous
abonner à notre pétrole
après chaque podcast on fait avec enfin
encore moins de filtres en fait que ça
s'appelle whisky et un après tout est-ce
qu'on discute de tout et de rien autour
de la conversation qu'on vient d'avoir
avec nicole d'hommes - fait abonnés van
paasschen le lien et dans la gestion du
podcast cette semaine cette semaine on a
reçu la seule et l'unique rosalie
vaillancourt était devenu son parc à sa
deuxième visite à chaque fois on rit à
chaque fois on y est
à chaque fois on était vraiment bonne
discussion citons menant des ondes qu'on
n'aurait pas pensé
c'est que c'est passé on a aux allées et
venues ici avec son naturel puis son
hyperactivité puissante et des aires
naturelles mais on s'est mis à parler de
sujets plus sérieux comme ben encore une
fois les dénonciations on est on a parlé
là dessus rosalie était quand même
vocale dans ce mouvement là on a parlé
ne raconte pas d'histoires sur une fois
de sa psychose raconter son son et et
qu'est ce qui se passe pour réel à nous
raconter on a parlé de bloquer une
entente de représentation de parler de
racisme grande récession qui touche à
plein de sujets
rosalie c'est une fille son niveau peut
paraître naïf peut paraître crash même
par être vulgaire mais il ya vraiment
une profondeur puis y'a vraiment des
thèmes qui dit un sous-texte super
important je pense que c'est une mort
est une personnalité qui est importante
au québec puis c'était vraiment un grand
plaisir de larceveau moi et puis les
enfants si vous aimez la conversation
participer encore une fois vous
connaissez comment ça se passe et tu es
commentaires lac est partagée par les
amis mais surtout apprécié la
conversation fait qu sans plus attendre
tout bon pas de quoi donc
donc mon écoute
[Musique]
ce 2007 2010 et est à l'écart de ça
c'était l'ascendant d'une douche bag
mais c'était vraiment ça a vraiment été
le destine mode le genre le douchebag
louis charles haas latchine strap des
syndicats n'apprécient pas trop jeune
pour voir seulement les gars mon
secondaire qui était juste dégueulasse
ici c'était il y avait pas de doute
balle ou d'autres moyens non j'étais à
cette nouvelle quand même douchebag sur
ses terres je pense que oui mais oui
laisser sa tête une douche est
maintenant non mérité ce qu'on appelle
des matches j'étais pratchett j'ai adoré
hatchet non gt gt j'écoutais des films
d'auteur puis j'ai acheté mon linge dans
des friperies le comme exemple comme
maintenant j'étais vraiment bizarre puis
commun que massa fly avec les autres
afin d'emballer y avait des filles
c'était comme top 6 à six drops de
grands voir des corps laisse jeter comme
à être c'est plus important qu'avoir
j'avais tchèque au mastic toulouse
non parce que tout le monde était mes
amis au final c'est comme ça possible
cgt bizarre mais les gens acceptaient
que ce sera bizarre et déjà deux ans
j'étais déjà drôle je pense que c'est ça
ma forêt d une savez tout allait faire
des jo plutôt gênant non non non
vraiment peur c'est que les intervenants
ces cas ça s'est fait jour que tu as
fait tes pièces le genre ah ouais bah
oui j'étais vraiment que même quand je
rentre à l'école et le monde sa a pris
peut-être 4,5 moules à me dire ah c'est
vraiment c'est fort je pense
ouais non pas du tout moustakas c'était
en 2014
mais après ouais bon d'accord c'est par
dans l'école femme âgée comme manger je
voulais pas faire juste les que je
voulais faire des enfants en même temps
on avait peur loi mais vous avez pas le
droit mais je pense qu'on avait pas le
droit parce que les conséquences
sur l'école pie mais c'est que je
voulais pas moi d'un coup je n'aime pas
se faire débat après l'école je veux
tout de suite j'ai pas essayé pendant un
an
faites moi car je suis né l'école tout
le monde me connaissait déjà fait que
c'était parfait c est beaucoup moins
qu'ils finissent écoles bien nuit arrive
le puits c'est de commencer les semis
qui l'attend massa s'est endetté plus
beau qu'avant je sais pas ce que je sais
à quel point ce serait trop beau c'est
ta tête tu as les deux fois en gaspésie
ouais commencer la gaspésie maintenant
apparemment que c'était la destination
touristique par excellence de tous les
québécois
mais ce texte mais également non talent
et la première fois en camping puis en
vannes puis on est allés fin juin enfin
qui avait posté pas encore si on a comme
commander nos places de camping en
savait même pas si on allait pouvoir y
aller encore plus est on est on est on
était comme des premiers arrivés le feu
n'était pas tant que petit à petit après
là il ya eu au moins ce qu'ils mangent
et j'aime c'est partant en vacances et à
des gens mais qui je comprends pas les
jeunes filles partent en vacances je
comprends pas les gens qui font ce
métier qui est le même mais dites moi
dans un métier qui te le permet tu mets
ton si j'étais je suis auto buzz
je faisais juste des vidéos youtube com
j'habiterai jamin morial j'habiterai
jardin en forêt en train de former vidéo
c'est vrai mais vittorio trentaine qui
fait des vidéos à la fête vidéo pour la
francophonie piéto mexicaine
m'a peut-être pas le mexique le costa
rica maintenant je sais pas ce que j'ai
dit bon enfin ouais c'est peut-être
thaïlande après 24 heures au plo d'être
vidéo et c'est ça qui a bagué encore
c'est le seul c'est le seul
las la fois que besoin parce que je
ferai le tour du monde est en quête me
déplacerai tout le temps bieleu mais
mettons parce que si tu voulais faire
juste des vidéos youtube qui pourrait
faire juste des vidéos youtube sûrement
été un sas rêve je pense que je pense
que non non non je sais pas à combien de
manquer je sais peut en fait combien je
suis d'argent je fais mais je pense pas
que c'est plus quelques hommes 200 parce
que non mais c'est que si tu voulais
faire ce jeu pourrait être tenté de le
faire + pioche et dix peintures en même
temps je sais pas chercher des sponsors
je me suis vraiment parlé avec la pub le
suivant coben genre t'es comme quelqu'un
me donne quelque chose de gratos à
chaque jeu comme ça va pas faire la pub
le puits même la porte du temps je
refuse maintenant page comme je m'excuse
mais petites antilles shojaee j'en ai
trop d tout léger je vais je veux pas
consommer davantage
oui je comprends je comprends mais m
j'ai essayé par la pandémie j'en ai fait
une vidéo par semaine ouais puis
honnêtement le plus que je me suis fait
je pense que c'est c'est 100 dollars par
mois
je serai avec avec son aval youtube que
les youtube en sont capables de vivre le
moi je ne sais pas comment ça fonctionne
en scolaire c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un cas tu fais une publicité ça
rentabilise mathon 400 une vidéo parce
qu'ils y font j'aurai une publicité dans
mon vidéo c'est comme un genre ben ouais
mais ton salut cette vidéo si présenté
par une compagnie brp harmonie tchoyi la
compagnie des arbres à manger tu as dit
prends tu es ton inspiration dans la
pièce
de quoi parle le mieux la compagnie fait
après si tu fais ta vidéo mais parce que
c'est du contenu gratuit du fait que le
monde tu les fais pas chier t'encule
en même temps moi quand allez vous faire
des jokes fait que ce pass minutes à
roissy s'est massé mes vidéos sont deux
minutes 55 ans parce que j'ai une pensée
deux minutes là dessus mais moi je vais
sortir bientôt n'est une nouvelle
websérie c'est moche j'aime beaucoup les
webséries pied on essayait de trouver
des sponsors
c'est vraiment difficile les gens ils
peuvent payer ses charges ne suis là que
tu demandes beaucoup que les gens sont
comme d'habitude c'est 500 places pied
arrêté que moi mais attend est pas la
même chose
c'est un peu le far west en soi mais en
terme de titres ce qui est web depuis
toujours la valeur de cette affaire
l'homme mais en même temps c'est que
selon les payent pour des pubs à radio
pirate et les x alors qu'il regarde ce
qui s'est dit et l'asie aux compagnies
vous mettez de l'argent dans un produit
qui bombent picon positive et écouter
exactement par le public que vous voulez
parce que excuse-moi les 20 35 ans il
regarde pas la télé non il faut regarder
nos vos points comme le jpeg jpg plus de
talent et ça fait deux petites arrivé
depuis me suis séparé de ses parts y
compris j'ai juste plus de télé juste
une bête juste pour rien j'ai vu sur des
coussins j'imagine qu'ils vont donner ne
t'avais pas une campagne coup 5 donner
des conseils
non on avait donné un os les oreillers
les oreillers woké mois maradona les
salariés pour leslie teale à savoir des
bleus défaits cette marche
plus rien non mais j'ai pas de télé ch
mais enfin merci mais à chaque fois que
j'ai annulé deux fois en fait c'est les
deux fois mais grand par et aimant ouais
mais au fait qu'est ce qu'elle est là et
on sait tous le sort ailleurs à cause de
toi jamais personnellement j'espère que
personne morale mais pas ce que je
cherche mais là tu peux tu es tu sûr sud
aidée des souvenirs de ce que je voulais
vraiment c'est mon père mon grand père
faisait des meubles ac là j'ai un gros
meubles dans ma chambre mais j'ai reçues
la grosse grosse télé le gigantesque
télé parce que etc il voyait pas bien un
fax est hyper groupe je me suis acheté
un enfer de spéléologie peut coller avec
des câbles je peux écouter la télé ça
coûte 14 pias suspecté est radical je te
laisse autant que lui oui mais non mais
non mais j'essaie mais honnêtement je
sais pas parce que je connais je pense
pas que c'est ça je pense qu'elle est
jeune on sait pas à quel point ça coûte
pas cher en garde et m'attends à 2,15 au
15 mars puis j'avais moi je pensais
qu'il fallait je m'abonne tout ça ce fut
compliqué avec d'autres on sait pas quoi
d'autre qu'à bas fonds non j'ai juste
cinq postes mais c'est les 5 postes ce
qui allait et bonhomme le matin match
correct je vous écoute n est qu un match
référence ce chiffre doit s'écouter mes
propres émissions le c'est tout lé
français que j'ai plein d'autres places
kara de cannes
[Rires]
[Musique]
la série est tournée non la tonne fin
septembre aux casseurs de
novembre/décembre mon espoir est la
sortir pour ma feuille comme on avait
fait avec l'autriche mais la mancelle à
sortir pour m'en fait avec maintenant
jusqu'où tu peux nous en parler mais je
peux en parler vous que c'est mon projet
mais maintenant c'est ma comédie
musicale faxing comédie musicale sur ma
vie ne mettent si c'est vraiment stupide
c'est par rosalie vaillancourt la
comédie musicale non bref moi j'adore
chanter pays danse et puis même si je
danse pas super bien puis chante mal je
trouve ça drôle de farce et télé c'est
vraiment excellent et même auteur qui
avait écrit avant d'être morte fin qui
s'est vraiment hein ça s'est ressenti
j'écris avec une fac c'est vraiment le
fun sandrine pialat l'ex qui s'entend de
sapia des danseurs yeux il ya mon passé
cette barre bull head et danny way ça va
être vraiment fun qu'il s'est tourné en
rimes est devant un green screen fax et
comme tout entre aude et puis ça va être
vraiment spécial qui compose comme suit
ces aides jsl vous connaissez c'est une
tonne par jour
on avait déjà composé la musique
trois ans et demi quatre ans parce que
j'avais fait la comédie musicale sur
scène mais là on écrit comme les
dialogues entre des petits dialogues
mais souvent c'était du stand-up tandis
que les jeux les remplacer pour que ça
soit comme et on l'a remplacé pour ce
soit vraiment aidé des sketches le dépôt
des sketches où c'est vraiment une
histoire qui suit sur le showbiz
québécois
on parle beaucoup des allégations
sexuelle on parle des difficultés
peut-être blanc ont tenté c'est drôle
les vert et blanc qui parle du faux mais
c'est super chiant c'est la chose la
plus intelligente stupide que j'ai fait
maintenant ça c'est plus compliqué puis
plus engagé m
j'ai engagé d'un monument mais souvent
ça se voit pas parce que les gens
pensent que c'est stupide
ouais ouais je m'appelle on avait parlé
après un peu tout est venu le tour
numéro sur ton site en recul
fuck la culture du viol c'est quand même
c'est juste une histoire où est-ce que
tu ris un peu de façon fort des quelque
chose qui est jeune belle et j'ai des
nouveaux numéros justement ce rêve
serait la violence conjugale
ouais puis c'est comme vraiment c'est
tellement sujet comment j'ai envie parce
que tes shsh com - c'est pas drôle des
blagues je suis celui qui ferait peu
dans la vie des gens il faut que ça soit
efossa sens évoqué c'est mon angle c'est
qu'en fait ce qui est arrivé c'est
pendant la pandémie et montre un
document c'est vraiment que les gens
vraiment intense puis on est
légitimement ciel par turf à clé les
voisins on pensait kim avait frappé ou
quelque chose ont appelé la police
la police a débarqué fin que j'explique
qu'est ce que la police fait quand ils
viennent chez vous pour violences
conjugales jeu comme au cas où si vous
savez rives pour s'y étaient pas accès
comme un copain 15 minutes sur la
violence cauchy ailleurs et c'est bon
c'est fait soit par les dents mais tu as
fais pas blesser personne mais tu veux
te plan arias pas ces gens parlent
beaucoup sur l'effet quai et une fois
qu'elle est une femme est une victime ou
un homme dès qu'on est victimes ont la
personne est juste une grande une
victime on oublie comment sa
personnalité 15 - fax et j'en parle un
peu le cas je t'ai jamais ce que je n'ai
pas été rose avait encore la victime va
bientôt arriver encore et la fille
aubenas craignent un autre cadeau
caractéristiques définies comme apte à
naviguer thiémé ton avec toutes les
histoires de la dénonciation pipe les
allégations commente à naviguer l'espèce
d'aspect demeurer de tandt a personne
qui est drôle qui humoristique versus la
personne qui se fait inviter dans les
entrevues pour parler de trucs faux king
pour humoristique la neige et j'ai
refusé toutes les entrevues
ah oui tu es entrain j'ai dit non parce
que j'avais quand même certains
témoignages dont je pense que c'est la
presse qui appelait devoir le devoir
ben si je me suis dit j'ai eu ça sans
rien en parler tout est dit la dame
s'est dit peu plus intelligemment qu'est
ce que je veux dire parce que je vais
sûrement me paraît motif puis si tu ne
sais jamais comment les gens vont
tourner ce
je voulais pas dire plus pitié d'un coup
qu'une enquête je lève des foires des
choses fait ça sans rien en parler plus
je pense que j'ai dit ce que j'avais à
dire puis ensuite des tirs et si je
voulais peut mettre dans mort de
quelqu'un ou avoir l'air de me faire la
sympathie sur cette aide aussi l'oeil
parce que c'est moi stereden chose que
je voulais avoir la cds profitez alors
que je voulais juste faire comme je suis
pas à l'aise mon ami m'a dit c'est vrai
qu'à me le dit pis que je la crois
franchir mais sus de prendre ce risque
est quand même courageux en guillemets
considéra qui est ici je t'aimerai
milieu dans lequel des volumes mais j'ai
eu moins pas maintenant de farce est
dans le devoir que quand j'allais dire
spécialement aux jantes et je les fais
tu là les dents voire des productrices
j'allais jamais voir des producteurs
mais j'arrive en des producteurs
disaient puis je trouvais ça plus
courageux qu'est ce que j'ai fait
maintenant ça se voit pas mais state of
puis à chaque fois je me souhaite
retourner une tige me suis fait des
genres et autres il plus qu'un victoire
faire qu'à ta place je te dirai rien
ça fait longtemps quand même si on est
amis sur facebook ça fait quand même
longtemps qu'ils partagent ces des
articles qui traitent du milieu de
l'humour de comment c'est un milieu qui
qui qui toxiques plusieurs raisons puis
c'est cette histoire le jeu tu as mal de
huy bac qui avait hier une liste qui
avait envoyé aux diffuseurs goethe en
2010 puis y'a rien qui a été faite le
des actions qui ont été faites iman même
moi je te présenter un élément je savais
pas pour julien avant janvier
faty comme jet set les cela j'ai je la
croyais si je la croyais vraiment mais
julien je croyais pas tout à fait comme
c'est tellement mon ami qui est gens qui
me disaient ah c'est une fille qui m'en
veut puis je le croyais mais d'autres
les autres je croyais pas pressé c'est
finalement c'est peut-être démarche
je ne savais pas avant que son extra par
lui avant que la commentaire parce que
tu m'as je me disais je sais comment
quelqu'un et soul adele me desgens bras
cette fois soulever maroobe honnêtement
je trouve et se tissent tcc centraux
mathieu savoir dans ce sens que je
trouvais
des coups de poing l'egypte a rien fait
j'ai commencé logement ils jugent
suspect comme c'était comme quasiment
fini mettez dans les dernières années
qu'on était mon ami jean ristat commença
était plus jeune homme épatant non plus
le tester c'était comme normal mais tu
disais dans l'article 6 à 12 ans qui
vous étiez comme plus éloignés mais
c'est par rapport à ce salaire par
rapport à ça c'est pas par excès plus et
fait 6 kg
moi je suis comme un peu et j'étais
comme un peu les bâcler dans le sens que
j'aime faire mon show qui je suis
vraiment pécho biais d'une envie le
genre 2-0 mes amis sont pas là dedans et
je me sens pas bien répartis je prends
pas de drogue
je bois pas beaucoup mais je me sens
tout le temps plate gens comparent à
tout le monde là dedans ça que j'aime
mieux chill avec mes amis qu'on fume
spots chez nous piquons garder film de
neil tsmc section hors ces impacts et
leurs actualités
deux fois par an c'est pas vrai s'est
passé c'est pas facile non plus de ce
milieu là dans son sketch veut tout le
temps être cool puis moi je veux pas
être cool genre j'aime ça être pas cool
c'est ma personnalité je sais ça puis ça
me dérange pas de pas être cool temps
qui est mon public me trouve cool
ouais puis que ça soit des gens pas cool
qui sera sur l'ensemble ça me dérange
pas mais c'est pas c'est pas nouveau
c'est quelque chose qu'on savait qu'on
entend de plus en tant que milieu de
l'humour mais temps où il ya quelque
chose qui cloche et que j'ai pas dire
les milieux du mans parce que youtube
heures du show biz le milieu de le
milieu culturel parce que l'on entend
aussi maintenant entre malté autres le
cirque problème je pense que le 1er
clément sait que c'est vraiment juste
des hommes titre personne pour me bats
qui m'attend cesser si je prends cette
décision là d'en parler ouvertement je
sais que j'aurai personne pour me back
et puis justement les personnes qui
m'ont baky koné a privé ne reçoit pas du
sport
oui j'en ai aussi un petit peu oui mais
mes projets reçus du 10sport des gens
qui étaient pas là dedans cg c'est pas
vraiment d'amis communs à moitié puis
julien qui m'ont écrit une bo doute pas
d'autre maurice le oui on a quelques uns
terry richardson qui est tout en feintes
et en heure
il y en a qui sont vraiment faim et puis
qui m'ont supporté ça me retombe j ai
dit oui tout ceci est fait
il a fait des choses pour que le prix
action et infractions sas et je pense
que c'est le seul
ouais mais ça c'est j'imagine que c'est
je me rappelle plus je pense que c'était
le podcast que j'écoutais hier le micro
emea avec jake moss qui disait jean
maintenant la balle est pas mal dans le
cas des gueules c'est là la balle est
dans le camp d'eggers d'agir comme les
faits on le dit il on le dit depuis fois
king longtemps c'était en fait d'agir si
ce que je trouve plate loi mais c'est ça
mais là c'est comme le spa mal autour
des godes de fort et là il ya quelque
chose qui se passe mais je pense que
quand on roule aussi dans ce sens que
c'est toi c'est important pour toi tu le
fais c'est juste s'ils les gars
réveillez vous soit faut que ça c'est
important pour vous c'est pas parce que
vous avez gardé des mongols ou en
allemand sait c'est qu'ils ont l'air
d'être tout ensemble puis d'être
d'accord avec ses actions avec un prix
je trouve c'est aussi un soutien pis si
on est solidaires liga sans jamais
changer mais aussi celle d'à mais pour
la bonne voie et c'est parce que tu es
en inde indigo qui équivalent à peine
puis il ya bien plus de gens animaux qui
sont anaïs que des gens qui sont pas à
un style c'est juste qu'on entend juste
parler des gens qui sont des gueules
mais c'est juste que c'est dommage qui
sapera faut que comme ça sorte pour que
le monde sait de ce city kaka quand il
déjà thème on essaie de jeu qui était
déjà au courant mais la fête ne sait
jamais à quel point c'est vrai il
précisé moi je peux même si j'en ai j'en
veux un petit peu a beaucoup de monde
dans ces dossiers là parce que j'ai eu
peur si j'avais peur je me sentais pas
bien j'avais parquet on m'enlève je
n'avais pas commencé ma carrière parce
que j'allais détruits
dans ma tête j'étais rendue folle et je
me disais qu'il allait y aller je pense
et aux amis de julien à la boîte à tati
j'allais par deux c'est ce que je trouve
le plus tôt fait maintenant j'ai pas
parlé dans ce sens qu'ils savaient
pourtant qu'ils savaient pas ta sont
mortes et jamais dit que quelqu'un c'est
paul j'étais comme les actions j'ai même
mangé j'ai été témoin des fois on ne
sait pas à quel point c'est un thé c'est
grave
cet acte mais si ça peut savoir à 100%
ils étaient étaient des gens disent
c'est jean-louis alimente tellement bien
témoigne aussi l'intérêt dans le sens
qu'il ne peut pas en vouloir aux gens
non plus et peu qu'ils ont convié
lillois puis là la semaine mais temps
après que ceux sortis tout est reçue
fait comme peux-tu toutes fermées et
hakim au jeu non je n'ai pas eu johnny
est ce que j'avais fait parce que je le
montrais comme que justement qu'est ce
tu est un ges comme anodin non sens que
je voulais je le faire comme elle c'est
pas incroyable de croire quelqu'un pour
incroyable de croke est ton ami peut
faire des mauvaises actions
voyons dans tes faux faux je voulais
vraiment pas vouloir de faire comme j'ai
fait quelque chose de gros j'étais
courageuse dealé avec ce mois je m'en
vais demain non non non non j'ai juste
cru mon ami points au pouvoir de dire
vingt six hôpitaux après armes à feu la
tête que c'est que c'est rare que je dis
est tellement de victimes piketty on
connaît tous des gens meurent tous les
jours dans notre entourage qui dit
comportements problématiques métier
juste alti la liste la fameuse liste le
anonyme quand l'ismans à l'ong le jury y
est tellement non là dessus qu'on
connaît tous quelqu'un connait tous
plusieurs personnes naturacam année si
on consomme à baky tout le temps les
gens qu'on connaît bon mais je pense
qu'il ya place à discussion je pense que
c'est si je pense vraiment beaucoup que
ça se peut la réhabilitation sa
spécialité quelqu'un qui a des
comportements déplacés une ou deux fois
je pense qu'il faut apprendre de cela je
pense que les gars doivent mais pas
juste et go les filles en a beaucoup de
faits aussi sur la liste puis je pense
que même manger
fait des actions des fois que je me sens
foule mais excusez je me suis excusé aux
personnes gées il ya des actions à
prendre je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
jeunes c'est je pense pas que les gosses
sont visés jusqu'ici on vise aiguë par
mois ils vont faire que bonnie poteau de
mouiller mais honnêtement tout le monde
en fait excusez vous excusez vous puis
essayer de penser qu est-ce que comment
on peut changer pour que ça soit plus
agréable
- tu veux te dit je pars dans les jours
après où la journée même temps de poster
une photo sur instagram t'ai écrit on
dans une nouvelle dimension
tu crois dessus l'autre l'impression
vraiment qui est comme acquis le le
message que julien avait mis genre non
dans une nouvelle dimension le puits
tout restait comme effrayant la clé
devant facile là son premier message est
ce que j'étais
zerah misérable mais moi ça mais ça m'a
fait du bien
j'étais fait que j'étais genre ok me
sentais moins mal parce que j'étais
tellement choqué si kezman dire c'est ce
message que tout à quel point qu'il est
méchant c'est vrai puis j'ai eu qu'une
introspection pilotes menés 0 méthode
ouais je pense que c'est sale ça le fait
que les gens encore plus cruel besoin à
ce qu'en disait j'ai aidé comme
quasiment merci légitimiser je pense que
je pense qu'elle est fan aurait pas cru
ce nom ait beaucoup de monde qui a
répondu parce que même les fans si tu
regardais les commentaires ce message le
même lit même le monde qui étaient
vraiment des femmes naissent déjà m
c'est débile ce que tu es d'écrire lui
de ouais mais je pensais justement vie
et les gens qui cache pas quel point
quelqu'un qui a des problèmes il y en eu
ya une course et c'est donc oui c'est ça
il va pas juste
violet du monde d'après ce dirigeant
j'ai fait mon introspection en un an
puis de façon intelligente cette
personne l'un des troubles
j'ai lu l'article puis j'ai compris les
choses ménagé c'est la même chose pour
les menaces qu'il est idiot j'ai compris
petits jeux comme terreau si les emails
en fin de semaine comment tu as pu
comprendre un tant de choses
puis un ton est respections se fait même
d apprendre des patins depuis changé
comportement ça peut tourner en mono
puce est correct
et tant pis si comme j'espère juste
honnêtement qui est il veut il va bien
aller comme toutes les guerres qui se
sont fait qu lot
je pense que ça veut pas dire lost on a
mixé fait qu'on leur avait pas dit
arrête de le voir ce à dire justement
soit là pour lui
des bonnes conversations avec exactement
pis si après ça j'ai un côté valeurs
votants sauf que si c'est quelqu'un
d'important dans ta vie piketty 6 pas
une mauvaise personne
or c'est tout comme kaki et des choses
qui sont belles de lui reste ouais ya
dessus et en thérapie taux d'intérêt
aucune nouvelle de julien helmand pythie
comme ça vu que ça faisait un petit bout
de quai on ne voyait plus est comme si j
aurais pas cette relation le recul ben
je l'avais mais ça faisait un petit bout
d'os qui étaient plutôt faibles puis
j'ai appelé au premier matin pour
dénoncer un élément je pense pas que
j'aimerais seuil paris
je me sens comme si je me sens qu'ils
m'ont marqué je sais que j'ai fait la
bonne affaire métier ça me dit ça m'a
fait de la peine j'ai pleuré la semaine
après le jt comme c c'est fou de penser
que je le reverrai pull
c'est un ami c'est quelqu'un que je
trouvais tellement drôle tellement d qui
étaient là j'étais comme je sens train
de regarder parce que j'étais comme
qu'est ce que ça a été difficile de
faire c'est aussi parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui était dans mon cercle
d'amis quand même en mauricie en est pas
une grosse gagne à avoir la même manche
à faire les mêmes à faty j'ai même sorti
avec son meilleur ami c'est comme ça
faisait partie des des gens que j'aimais
beaucoup fac ccsa et étoffé mais en même
temps j'étais comme paca par le pôle
fois c'était plus fort que moi je fais
comme je veux je veux pas participer
parce que ça fait trois ans justement
que j'en parle sur mon facebook et ça
serait tellement stupide au porc y est
fort ce serait pas au moins est ce que
tu sais mettons dans après la vague du
mythe où il ya vraiment un genre de
ralenti puis s'est un peu sorti de là la
conversation publique le t elle
la toxicité de certains milieux
la première vague après midi
exact après seul comme ça c'est comme
tomber un peu dans l'oubli ps qu' est-ce
qu'il ya eu des mesures qui ont été
prises après après cette vague là des
dénonciations en 2018
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui ont
changé ou pas du tout puis après ça le
deuxième pan de cette question là c est
ce que après ce qui vient de se passer
laisse croire qu'il ya des mesures qui
soient prises
bon pour ce que c'est 2018 je pense
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup de
mesures qui ont été prises
je pense que c'est plus c'est petit
c'est sûr qu'ils aient été mettant le
grand manitou du mot c'est le gars qui
tirait toutes les ficelles était un
violeur en série
je le balance est parti juste le fait
que sa charge majine que ça ça découle
le tri dans tous ses sens qu'il ya des
c'est juste y ait des changements il est
beaucoup plus de place aux jeunes
- ils prennent au sérieux car j'y vais
pas travailler que cette personne ne
dégèle c'est déjà bien
4 5 personnes que jamais j'accepterai
d'être sur le même plateau le même show
puis une fois que c'est arrivé j'étais
vraiment fâché comme un producteur
je pense que ce seuil et les gens
respectent un petit peu plus les choix
des tissus mai 2018 les choses qui ont
changé c'est que lyonnais je pense que
ça rien changé parce que même même les
gens qui étaient sur la première liste
il ya déjà qu'ils ont qui ont eu moins
de contrôles mais c'est parce qu'ils
étaient moins connus je t'ai mettons que
la personne n'est pas connu ça changera
rien à ma vie qui enlève une opportunité
de faire un peu d'argent ou tu fais ça
tu enlève quelque chose les gens unis
veulent pas un témoin je te connaissent
ça m'enlève de quoi le travelling fléchi
sauf que c'est important pour moi même
chose pour laisser golos et moelleux qui
pendant 500 pièces quand j'ai peu joué
yab ressort et à l'étoile avec hull
c'est moi qui le parent peut même pas ce
que vivent une seule chose mais si mal
vu quelque chose pour me sentirai mieux
au final mais il ya beaucoup de monde
qui sont pas prêts à faire je me sens
pas prêt à faire ce piquet s'était pas
comme si les dix ans pourquoi maintenant
une frais teste encore c'est bien moins
pire qu'il ya dix ans le minul
l'autre point aussi dans tout ça c'est
que toi tu es quand même une humoriste à
succès qui vaut ma chance elle va
réussir à travailler même si tu y mets
ton toit est halal allaster mettons d'un
plateau si tout vas voir le producteur
dit moi je pars avec cette personne là
il risque de t'ecouter plus que
quelqu'un qui apporte ton statut qui
arrive qu'à moitié
mettant kiki qui peinent à rejoindre les
boues qui peine à percer le milieu qui
fait et moi je veux battre avec cette
personne n'est pas tant la wii je suis
vraiment chanceuse puis même je pense
que si j'avais été aussi extrémisme ton
dans mes débuts je pense pas que
j'aurais fait une carrière c'est sûr
parce qu'elle était au début ce que j'en
parlais pas c'est juste que je t'ai juge
ove comprends pas comment un milieu - je
veux faire mes petites affaires de mon
côté comme en année j'ai fait comme je
suis dans ce milieu le physique preuve
choix de travailler avec ces gens je me
laisse aller ça commence à me peser je
trouve ça plate que les filles ou les
mêmes il ya des gars aussi qu'ils
reçoivent je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
se sont fait agresser par d'autres
mandant minutes cédées gueule mais au
début je pense je pense que j'avais 22
ans et quand j'ai commencé
c'est juste un petit peu plus certaines
de mes convictions maintenant on
s'entend puis au 6 mai je laime faisant
un petit peu peur dès le départ son
casting faut pas seulement parce que tu
veux jouer c'est drôle je veux juste que
les gens se souviennent que tu es
content knightley tu es quand on a su
par semaine cela parce qu'ils veulent
pas entendre parler d'une fille qui fait
comme j'arrive mais je peux passer sous
la clé une limite c'est cela
si béton tout justement la rosalie de 22
ans versus 27 ans allait évoluer métier
toutes ces mouvements là c'est comme des
abeilles collectif aussi le cpie
amanites sera pas la seule à dire c'est
passionnant je peux travailler avec
amman il ya un producteur d'une émission
en productrice d'émissions bâti sera pas
la seule à mener ses affaires qui n'ont
cette personne ne dit même si je pense
aussi à terme d'argent les hormones gens
vont se rendre compte qu'ils étaient
s'associe à des gens mais les matchs ont
la vie à pleines mains qui ya une fille
qui me disait mon porte ares est un
idéaliste neige ski puis l'année d'avant
c'était quand il s'appelle un autre
chanteur qui s'était fait le héraut
exactement l'état comme j'essaye pas que
choisi cette année pour me représenter
il fallait que ça soit un gain pour
tafer loeb c'est comme si un ennemi il
faut que tu choisisses vraiment bien
parce que ils perdent vraiment boucles
argentées allez venez s'ils ont perdu
tellement lent jean pascal et y aller
poster y aller tout organisé puissant vu
que les contrats sont signés sont
obligés de donner son argent quand même
ce sont les victimes collatérales c'est
toujours dommage pour le monde m'est on
sait qui est qui et on veut travailler
mais ton chez polti une partie des
années sur une émission sur quelque
chose si keynes à la constation télé
québec parce que la musique
au début c'était yann perreau sellal et
generix group de toute émission c'est ça
que je t'aime apprécié jarre penser à
comment qui avait fait l'émission pipe
de quéven pen dans l'émission ça il y
avait une perruque chanter ou
ça va être comme compliquée en 8 métissé
c'est quand même la différence c'est une
mission puis c'est un jugement mettons
de mettons tout en voir en prison
versus tu te fais enlever des privilèges
dans la vague de dénonciations en ligne
ce qui se passait c'était pas si c'était
pas des jugements c'était juste inquiet
tout les privilèges que tu avais mail on
les enlève tes au même titre que quand
quand élève un enfant puis que là il
fait quelque chose de répréhensible sua
qui mêle est relevé à 7 heures pour
regarder yu gi oh
avant d'aller à l'école là tu peux plus
on allait à l'école parce que tu as
abusé de yu gi oh ça va mal à l'école
mais c'est ça exactement je pense que il
ya aussi l'effet qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui veulent pas voir leur agresseur
elle en prison
sincèrement ce qu'on veut parce que matt
y en a qui croient pas aussi à la prison
acté c'est tj pas que je crois pas mais
disent c'est pas moi de choisir aussi
pour les victimes
j'ai même péter était d'un match profite
in des gpo été victime de ring factice
je peux pas envoyer en prison pour cela
bon ce club mais je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui veulent pas
envoyer les gens qui veulent que ça
arrivait tous et c'est vraiment long
c'est vraiment vraiment plate petit même
l'article
ça fait depuis février qui était écrit
depuis février qui se faisait écrire en
fait le pacte et c'est vrai que ça fait
un bond que ça que c'est lol super
récemment un lien direct avec justement
la vague qui a dit ça je pense que ça le
fait qu'ils saluent sa le accéléré
l'article parce que là il ya des filles
qui voulait plus parler puis c'est les
gens ont vraiment dit beaucoup mais
aller
allez dire aux policiers en place de
façon à g et vous majeur c'est un
message une policière qui m'a écrit à
cause de la vague de dénonciations
on a deux à trois fois plus de monde qui
viennent nous voir enfin que ça servait
à quelque chose c'est pas juste aux
heureux d'y aller mais oui peut-être que
cette personne ne veut pas y aller mais
à cause qui est cette personne a parlé
d'autres personnes qui sont allés eux la
voir c'est que c'était citons agresseurs
gérer ces conversations là cette semaine
c'est un agresseur est pas une
personnalité publique de le coller halte
dans sur instagram ça va pas il fera
perdre des privilèges c'est parce qu'il
pense qu'il y en a pas d'avancée haut
niveau dans la rue dans la vue du public
permettant une vague de dénonciations
que tout était une victime
tu dis ok le mois c'est quoi mes recours
parce que ça sert à rien que je garde
mon agresseur que personne connaît qui
travaille travaille mais je vois le fait
que c'est sûr qu'il ya eu plus de
dénonciation politique
chaque fois que tu veux une annonciation
ça te rappelle que tu es tout seul que
tu t'en fous tu es popol typique est
exactement
beaucoup de monde sic et ça leur fait du
bien juste des de voir quelqu'un qui
croie t'es juste de se faire dire par un
ami je te crois pied honnêtement j'ai j
même si j'ai pas vécu une agression
quand j'en ai parlé à des amis qui m'ont
dit mais moi je le crois pas ces
développements sur julien da manha ça me
faisait autant de lapins chacun un
échange et péter victime parce que mon
ami qui se rendait qui est ce que ça
fait que le pull goût d'en parler à la
juste le goût de santé tout sait jamais
comment quelqu'un peut nager tellement
en premier lieu je croirais après s'être
la compagne qui laissait kitty faisant
fonds n'appartient pas de casse mais il
faut aussi défendre notre image qu'on a
de l'agression sexuelle puis de ce que
c'est et ça peut arriver en couple ça
peut arriver
des fois c'est pas nécessairement avec
l'impression qu'un couteau à la gorge le
cccd des situations qui qui paraissent
grise en premier lieu mais qu'il quitte
qu'ils sont pas mais celle ci s'était
jamais l'idée qu'on consulte répit et le
parquet je pense qu ils vraiment
beaucoup d'agressions sexuelles qui
parle parler sexisme genre de se voir
plus ok
la personne puis juste seul je suis je
pense que cette agression
en partant car tu étais juste sexy cela
était même les filles qui agresse
d'autres filles j'ai l'impression sa
part du sexisme et ça va être des
commentaires sur leur apparence et ça va
être beaucoup c'est beaucoup dans le
sexe c'est ce que je pense et agression
sexuelle ça montre à quel point une
société sexiste le sexisme est
profondément ancrée à wave vraiment un
petit j'avais lu ce matin je pense 16e
vivement injustement qu'il dise ok il ya
50% les gens au uk qui disent que les
féminines c'est allé trop loin et comme
je les lui ce matin aussi ce qu'en
bizarre comment tu peux dire qu'elle
fait mener c'est allé trop loin ccpt
après ça dit allez trop loin ça veut
dire qu'une ligne d'arrivée puis on
s'aime et on la ligne d'arrivée c'est
l'égalité on sera allé trop loin
piti la pression a fait la liste c'est
des inégalités de pouvoir qui a été
maître tous les dirigeants
c'est maintenant la grosse majorité des
dirigeants de pays sont des sommes déjà
dans l'intérim dans le sport dans tes
partout tu regardes dans les histoires
partout où tu regardes les hommes encore
santé kennedy la riche comme un ensemble
qui en a des autrices qui mériterait
d'avoir maintenu au kennedy 76 % qui
disait dans l'article des noms de rues
tous des noms de hunt et qu'après ce
après on fait la liste de ce fait la
liste des comas kibet les chiffres les
violences et les violeurs les noms de
femmes disparues les au québec les
femmes autochtones disparues
les violences sexuelles violences
conjugales psicom je pense pas qu on est
on est allé trop loin je pense pas qu'on
va trop loin démarre dès que ça y est ma
télé je sais c'est dans le milieu de
l'humour c'est il ya des inégalités puis
il se vend des gens qui disent ouais
mais c'est facile pour une feuille
maintenant mais je pense pas non le ccc
ce que moi j'ai la chance d'avoir des
contres ou compass en audition peut plus
souvent sauf que le nombre de rôles ça
va descendre 20% le ton oui j'ai plus de
chances d'avoir le rôle compte tenu du
pourcentage ok il ya moins drôle fait qu
il faut qu on est trop à passer tu étais
peut-être 6 sauf que vous avez deux trop
rôle de go de rôle dans l'émission nuit
en a un
puis leur rôle et moyens drôle en plus
d'être fait tu m'étonnes à l'humour le
mettons deux humoristes de ton âge ou
plus jeune maton le vraiment il la
relève rio dessus proportion ils sont en
proportion plus grande de films et on
voudrait c'est quoi la proportion se
fait pas sans mal un plus grand nombre
de cas j'ai commencé et que je connais
pas les proportions et epic games et je
sais que maintenant sous caution
l'argent c'est un hymne au québec je
pense qu'on est prise dans les flammes
de 15-20 je sais pas le progrès soit
s'engueule plus que je pense parce que
tu es moche compte les filles qui sont
peu connus mais qui font des corps pop
qui vivent très bien leur vie comme si
on doit être juste 15
je pense qu'on ait ces fous pareils
c'est d'école cinq ans à épiler ccss et
15 filles mais comme elle est femme et
tes racisées là dessus et encore moins
il est un peu gênant ben ça c'est dans
tout ça c'est vraiment magique et bruno
sekoli cement gênant que ça prenne la
star original mais on a quand même c'est
bizarre parce que tg savez c'est un peu
quoi vous êtes même j'ai jamais regardé
c'est quand même un petit peu bizarre je
n'ai pas gardé m'étais apparemment c'est
un show qui parle de ce qui fait la
force de ce texte en l'état les fans
assez juste
policiers comme un autre mais plus parce
que voulait représenter québec mme après
sèche comme pourquoi vous voulez tout le
temps reprise en force et c'est tout
temps a présenté beaucoup on n'est pas
de l'avant puis justement on défonce
fixé à ses ports représentatif mais
crime
on apprend sur d'autres fois parce que
toutes les sexy spi la culture les les
autres cultures ça passe par la télé les
journaux mais ici chaque jour dans ma
télé je vois quelqu'un latino qui me
fait rire que je trouve autre que je
m'attache à sa famille crème que ça se
peut qu'elles soient moins à six après
le oui quand j'ai 14 ans genre oui c'est
ça même si même chose pour une fille -
15 14 mais dans mes salles
il y en a beaucoup aidé des jeunes
gueule c'est mon peuple préféré page
comme ces j'aime beaucoup les faits
aussi mais je me dis tout le temps quand
quand tu vois ce jeune qu'elle soit une
fille qui capable de s'exprimer qui
aiment se parlent et qui se fait écouter
puis qu'il ya même des monsieur 60 ans
qu'ils écoutent mais ça me donne le goût
de respecter un peu plus les filles
après peut-être le thymol petit je veux
représenter le québec mais il ya un
problème de représentation qui avec ses
méthodes à la police par exemple et à
qui on veut représenter un corps policy
une normale mais si on le sait que ma
tante et on a parlé avec web seguin qui
venu on le sait qu émettons une personne
autochtone une personne noire cette fois
plus de chances de se profiler par la
police à l'entrée du goût des ventes
risque tabagisme et ce par souci qui
marque de noir de tokten d'arabes dans
la police ce tri fait factice arrêté
avant gardiste de faire un show
d'inclure ce pur pour payer un petit
gars qui se voyait tv et bien écrit mais
le policier dans le fond ça ça peut
s'adresser à moi et c'est ça qui m'a
souvent d'effets à sa m'énerve de devoir
être autant c'est là le modèle c'est
parce que souvent tu mets ton moi
j'avais demandé à marianne un crime
pourquoi est on pas passer une audition
petit comme mais ça me tentait pas ça me
tentait juste pape si j'étais quand même
et est pas responsable de représenter
donc toutes les femmes 1 timmins et
arabes s'est dit mais j'ai quand même eu
tu as raison mais je pense vraiment que
c'est parce que c'est sûr que c'est pas
je pense et patrick erard qui est
derrière cette cette émission lol ouais
pitié choc c'est pas c'est pas dit
activement j'apprends des blanquetiers
mais je pense que je pense que la
question vient vraiment à il faut
activement faire le contraire c'est faux
la responsabilité revient à tout le
monde activement prendre des mesures
mais c'est juste que c'est c'est
beaucoup plus est en tête si je pense
qu'ils ont juste et paresseux c'est
facile de se déprendre de blanchet belle
convoité l'est plus tout le monde aime
déjà parce que trouver deux femmes
maintenant actrice qui sont drôles
puis qui fit c'est ça doit être très
fort puis je pense que honnêtement il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se font qui se
fait dans la vie dans le casting sauvage
le commander une étude de voir la
personne marché quasi type etr eacom
sortie parce que les agences et celle ci
voici ma platine ans plus tard peut-être
pas devenir actrice mais aussi parce
qu'elle envoyait maintenant dominique
michel
mais se dit à une femme blonde excité
ses hôtes c'est j'ai vu quelqu'un qui me
ressemblait c'est j'espère que
honnêtement je t'aime modèle sécheraient
vraiment fier d'être un modèle pour des
petites filles non des petites filles
latine en mai je sais qu'ils en font un
modèle qui est fort killer qu'il
représente un peu plus tes bêtises parce
qu'ils sont on dirait que c'est vraiment
le problème de casting on dirait que
c'est un sou problème selon moi si je
vends à trouver du monde qui sont
talentueux c'est vraiment plusieurs
comprendre ce sont à ces dix on peut
dire qu'on pense les pis c'est pas
facile les auditions c'est vraiment
gênant c'est que je pense que
honnêtement souvent même moi quand je me
fais un casting je vais d'en faciliter
des gens que je connais je vais pas
commencer à faire un casting d
1 cd savage piégeant que choc qui
jouerait mieux que telle personne tant
que telle personne je contacte j'ai
passé des solutions c'est peut-être
leicester qui sont nécessaire d'être
prix ces mets ton oui ça va être plus
compliqué où il va falloir tout le monde
certes la zone de confort on peut pas
juste engagé le monde qu'on connaît déjà
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est un
destin parce que sa lettre plupart des
grosses agences qui donne l'exemple qui
comme c'est maintenant juste le killing
c'est comme des genres que personne
n'avait vu avant puis il me tend mettre
de gros noms mais le gosse parce qu'il
connaissait des gens qui était bon le
voyez vraiment chanceux mais c'est super
difficile de trouver des gens qui sont
bons que ceux connus poule
ce sont les connais pas factice et sacs
et puis en plus de ça quand tu fais pas
de théâtre où tu fais pas d'un pro piqué
puis qui a été quelqu'un d'un autre
milieu c'est vraiment difficile d'avoir
accès à ces gens le pis c'est ce que je
trouvais plus tough le plus le plus
proche cette rencontre était finalement
t'es juste des ânes blancs
ce serait céder gala c'est comme de dire
sa magie
gg j'ai des amis noirs j'ai des amis
mais j'en sais j'ai mes amis arabes
meetic juste de les appeler mes amis
arabes cgt chanceuse des délais de les
rencontrer ce parce qu'on fait du monde
toutes les deux tu as quittés c'est plus
facile d'avoir le contact mais sinon
comment je vais rencontrer chaliand une
école privée à saint-hyacinthe dans un
but le plus blanc au monde il ya eu un
noir à mon école
c'est difficile je pense que la
rencontre des cultures est vraiment plus
tôt compensé pour ce qu'il faut pas en
activement bbd des façons
individuellement de de faire que ça
change
métis de commandes occasion maquis parce
que telle ou telle montréal est très
très diversifiés puis le risque avec
vraiment à paul matte en août mais
qu'est ce qu'on pense
bâti au bout et c'est sur que c'est pas
comme en réalité nous à marjah on est
comme c'est vraiment bizarre c'est
maintenant moi j'ai regardé les regards
les émissions pis honnêtement je sais je
vois comme ci habitait à montréal on
voit le pauvre tatata c'est les mêmes
enjeux sauf qu'il ya une grosse danser
la population quand même pas lui qui
peut représenter même
même en forme mais bien moins de femmes
que d'hommes dans l'émission puis comme
pourquoi je comprends ça cabinet
d'avocats le moment donné on n'est même
plus avant que d'hommes c'est soit parce
que les émissions après ceux qui les
consomment si tout le québec tpiy puis
après ce bel le décret des émissions chi
chi chi chi chi les gens pour rythmer
justement certaines occasions avec des
gens qui t'a fait sauter de voir une des
réalités que tu connais pas puis de
d'apprendre justement des candidats qui
me blesse le plus avec les êtres humains
que je pensais souvent quelque chose
être humain mais moi ce qui me gausse
ses dépôts étaient pas capables de
menthe hachée mais moi je suis capable
je pensé mais c'est quand même difficile
pour beaucoup de monde de sa tâche à
quelqu'un qui leur ressemblent pas je me
trompe peut-être que moi raymond
humoriste préféré ça sera un homme
chinois de 70 ans je sais pas parce que
j'ai pas cherché ce cg cherche des
femmes aux états unis déterrage taloche
qui ont un humour un petit marsan mais
c'est souvent les gens m'ont cherché
quelque chose qui leur ressemble
tellement qui passe à côté des quelqu'un
peut-être qui les ferait changer d'idée
changer de plein d'enfants puis c'est
tellement on est tellement égocentrique
de penser de même que je me sens tout le
monde est un peu comme seul nom les tout
on veut que ça nous ressemble
c'est sûr tripy tu parlais des forts
conscients puisse aussi c'est une autre
chose que chacun doit faire cette
responsabilité de thé d'essayer de voir
l'autre côté de la médaille de s'exposer
à l'étranger si tu voyages un minimum si
tu sais je sais que ce pôle d'aig pour
tous l'expérience et c'est ce que tu
peux voyager c'est gaspésie en camping
c'est déjà une grosse quand sa pitié
justement non cachetée il y avait et je
pense qu avait des gens qui sortaient de
montréal pour la première fois l'at il y
avait des gens qui il y avait des
personnes immigrantes qui était venu au
camping tout le monde en parle et d'en
gaspiller week avait déjà une grand
camping des séquelles avais dit le mot
des maladies comme quelque chose d'un
peu race et seule avait dit genre il ya
d ailleurs le capitaine
elle a dit quelque chose comme un petit
peu ce test et poste est pas fin mai
avait précédé comme si le funky soeur de
maria pour nouveau titre était cassé et
c'est à eux que je pense que la
rencontre s'est fait mal parce que on a
pas de discussion c'est même encore là
on est des blancs qui parle tout seul
mais ça c'est la même chose ceux ci
pourraient les faits mais les films
monsieur stehli les mosquées c'est un
couple homosexuel ou un couple lesbien
ou bi ou n'importe quoi on sent pas
attacher si ça ressemble pas un
notre couple hétéro c'est souvent encore
les représentations je te demande de
diversité au québec ça fait le fait que
ce soir ou même parlement par son amant
le fait qu'ils soient pas comme toutes
les autres
c'est un des aspects qui forment
l'intérêt de leurs personnages à l'écran
et on sait maintenant le couple
homosexuel yapo lot s'est adressé le
fixe homosexuels 6 laurent je sais que
c'est un couple homosexuel
attends moi j'avais j'avais luc spacek
était l'fun à un personnage à rita c'est
qu'elle était bisexuelle mais que comme
on s'en foutait depuis que c'était
plutôt un mandat était arrivé dans le
store sextape à était pas là pour
représenter les bisexuels ccc même
affaire pour les personnes n'importe
quelle personne stern de représenter les
femmes dans un show s'est pas présenté
les femmes je voudrais présenter les
gens qui aiment parler
en fait les gens absurde un peu sexuelle
c'est ce que je veux représenter je peux
représenter les femmes parce que j'ai
pas le décevoir après ça les femmes
c'est beaucoup de pression le pour faux
car la tis
ça sert à quoi que je représente les
femmes ne pige pas nécessairement la
meilleure représentante peut-être des
femmes quitté ya peut-être des plus
d'acquis même quête femme petit set ça
veut rien dire ce soit quelqu'un calmes
et on ya un festival
tu dois rentrer dans la catégorie de
comac et on a on a tant de femmes
invitées on évalue trop on évite rosalie
et puis comme on va de l'avant dans la
représentation que tu le veuilles ou non
si après ça et c'est un c'est à chacun
d'eux est ce que tu veux faire ça mais
je pense que de représenter quelque
chose je pense être au choix dira oui
parce que sinon tu pas de double métier
avec le noir des services avec la fille
de 7 ans
ces écoles se baisse pour le fun et
sympa quand même sympa bien que
j'imagine que dans un monde idéal on
n'aurait pas besoin de mettre des
dichotomies centraux bon encore moi je
pense qu'un minimum de filles sur un
choses m'ont aidé fils que je vois
jamais parce qu'on ne m'ait jamais sur
le même show plonge comme crème
peut-être que ce serait ma mère a une
tête que ce serait la personne avec qui
j'ai qu'il mieux boulet gueuse avait
juste eu toute la chance de vous
rencontrer mais moi si je vois jamais
mon landry comment je peux savoir que
c'est pas la personne avec qui
j'aimerais le plus travaillé finalement
lui enlever cette chance l'aide de tous
de se rencontrer de se connaître
nous les filles on ne voit pas on moule
on ne voit pas ce que des fois sur un
groupe on écrit comme les choses qu'on
reçoit assez lisse ne se parleraient peu
près jamais tu l'as où la
représentativité le thé le meilleur show
que j'ai vu ou est ce que justement tu y
mets ton l'homosexuel dans l'émission
hip hop juste là pour être homosexuel
seuil d'autres nos aspirations you do
struggle et hop rallier d'autres puits
mettant l'immigré assez sexy qestion
jeté sous un bus ce moment c'est
vraiment bon parce que lost et dans une
école c'est comme un show propos radio
classique en guillemets c'est ok c'est
au uk puis tout le monde de partout
d'autres plaintes ont troqué sa part est
par exemple que ça a été fait pour être
plus ces problèmes étaient à être plus
est ouverte et ça paraît que c'est
cholet s'était fait pour ce pays je
trouve ça génial c'est tout les autres
shows pouvait représenter ce mais je
trouvais que ça c'était comme me ton c
est vraiment un sport encore le moi ce
que je me demande c'est les gens qui
sont pas intéressés par ce qu'ils
veulent écouter maintenant l'heure bleue
comment avoir fait pour passer des
émissions comme ça moi je comprends je
comprends mais vu que vu que mettons les
personnages d'embêter où je comprends
que je comprends que c'est une décision
consciente de le faire de même mais je
trouve pas que c'est forcé le trouvez
comment font ces diversités tpiy
justement j'ai vu que les personnages là
dedans ils font juste à être pittis
programme important l'attend sexuels
d'où ils viennent pour certains oui pour
d'autres pop adulte cpc c'est vraiment
bien qu'ils étaient même dans la
dernière saison le gars qu'on était tout
attaché à lui vient un peu on finit par
là et on est comme crise aidant mètre
carré d'as qui ressemble au gré de son
âge au final il ya des désirs que ça le
fauche un peu le quand quelqu'un dit non
c'est vraiment bien et qui puis vu que
c'est vu que les personnages là si je
pense que n'importe qui pouvait l'être
le pti c'est comme universelles les
styles de chacun ses goûts du moins de
monde peut se reconnaître dans un des
personnages même si lui ressemble
physiquement par exemple s'effectue sur
c'est vraiment cool fac team et ont fait
un show de fait le même show québec mais
du producteur de mondes différents
pictures parfois de l'adresse mais des
fautes et paul nous sommes obligés de
l'adresser ça fait que tim est on sur
certains points sommes heureux car est
un personnage mais pas parce que y est
parce qu'il m'aime était avec moi plutôt
que le même couleur de peau ou moi ou
que l'on aime t c'est ça il faut pas
oublier aussi que au québec on n'est
vraiment pas beaucoup à faire ce métier
c'est pas hyper payant quand on fait pas
beaucoup beaucoup bac c'est sûr que les
gens acceptent les contres c'est moi
j'ai entendu rend beaucoup le monde
charlie contre les actrices qui avait
accepté l'hérault et puis quelqu'un au
nom mais bon ça mais ça a été un e je
sais qu'il y en a qui était parti de me
dissocier cette semaine pied mylène
c'est quelqu'un avec qui je m'entends
quand même bien m'acheter comme ici
tellement peu de leur folle on peut
perdre sa oui exact mais je pense pas je
pense quand même pas si live changing
non mais je vous en mets toi pour ta
carrière pour propulser cholet
mais je pense pas que ses deux fils
avaient besoin de ce rôle que ces
m'attend je pense que c'est le jeu de
l'actrice connue ces deux actrices déjà
témoin tu quel point tu étais là c'est
juste que les producteurs si c'était pas
7 6 y avait dit non on voudrait prendre
a pris notre s'il me l'avait proposé je
pense que la prochaine fois c'est pas
moi ça ça où l'on apprécié ces 18 mois
le changer pour fanny il y aura pas on
n'a pas trouvé on a vraiment cherché je
sais pas ce que j'aurais fait
honnêtement c'est au flat du réputé je
parle de tout sans lever des privilèges
pour mais ça c'est un privilège que j'ai
honnêtement j'ai bien beau mais me
retourner c'est pas un privilège comme
on lève c'est mon rêve
ac c'est super dur mais encore là je
pense que ça serait pas mal de labour je
pense que sa responsabilité
je pense que la responsabilité de
l'actrice de prendre cette décision mais
encore une fois ces deux femmes qui sont
enlevés des affaires n'est peut-être
plus de femmes est à placer des pays
européens mais c'est ça c'est vraiment
les décisions qui viennent d'en haut il
faut que la direction et ça m'a surpris
qu'ils prennent pas lé d'euros les
femmes qui ne changent pas pour deux
gueules des anglais mais s'ils veulent
vraiment représenté québec
ouais c'est sûr c'est juste un matin
lâcheté quelle genre de chalets sur le
site de deux clubs radios l'est qui
genre de commerce les troubles il ya six
personnes non il ya eu huit personnes ie
6 go deux filles sont toutes deux leurs
pions tout en haut de 45 m2 du christ on
peut avoir un petit peu de diversité
toutes sont dédiés tant intellectuelles
de province pour par quebecor le même
temps ouais c'est pas choisir un comète
et si c'est du seul à parler quand et
impôts des personnes et minorité mais
oui mais en même temps ce parce que
c'est le slogan constante si ce n'est
pas parler pour les autres
vas tu peux pas parler pour les autres
mais tu peux parce que toi maintenant le
je prends mon exemple moi c'est sûr
qu'ils aient pleinement dans le monde
qui me suivent mon public a hâte leurs
jeux tiers en guillemets qui a besoin
d'entendre certaines choses par rapport
à ce qu on peut pas juste déférer la la
conversation va vers des personnes des
personnes des personnes noires mettons
parce que zotti ils parlent à leur
public qui est déjà possiblement et qui
comprennent déjà beaucoup de concepts
qui sont pas intégrés par tout le monde
fait que c'est sûr que si ces personnes
blanches privilégiés on n'a pas le choix
dit exactement c'est maintenant moi j'ai
ben beau affirmer qu'elles m'ont et sexy
les gens qui m'écoutent
c'est des gens qui sont pas sexy il
vient d'avoir un show déjà le nom chez
des billets pour voir une famille
maurice de 27 ans l'affecter c'est u 17
personnes est déjà super ouverte
d'esprit chapeau converti faudrait qu
richard martineau fajjar dans son
émission il fasse que my life a manqué
diversité au québec des médias c'est
parce que parce que si son public qui a
besoin d'entendre ce serait non mais je
sais mais tu maîtrises mettons dans un
monde parfait c'est cet auditoire là
qu'il faut que tu rejoins avec ces
messages le mari pour aller chez eux le
lendemain il se révèle en fait les trois
écluses et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
comme inception rendent dans son sommeil
puis on essaie d'aller changer la
cuisine cette fille d'un gentil chez eux
dans leur lit le projet mais c'est quand
même leur part les insectes pleut je me
demande qu'est-ce qu'il commet qui sont
pour de vrai je peux pas croquer mais
j'ai vraiment bizarre à croquer les gens
sont méchants du début à la fin il est
ce que l'on croit c'est sûr que non mais
le problème mais dont parce que je suis
sûr que je regarde pas d'avoir des
discussions avec ces personnes le nom je
pense qu'ils sont quand même va même et
à rencontrer les gens et pour d'avril
mais je pense que le problème c'est que
même si mettons à meudon conz a exhorté
dans leurs chroniques
tout le la décision d' exagérés et
qu'ils aient rendu est rendu trop grave
pour ignorer tu peux pas juste faire et
non mélange exagéré pour déclic non non
ce n'est pas ça mais j'ai passé des mois
et jean martinon je pense c'est mon
personnage préféré au québec on est
mariés tellement compris et fait passer
c'est très intelligent est tellement
intelligent qui est fêtée avant il était
comme un peu plus est il était un peu
plus de dos c'est exactement
j'ai tellement pas de devenir tellement
pas un jour imaginé le sang et par et le
mot n'est comme folle est folle de
droite ça sera très sain et guy au
maximum et les années ont pas fait le on
peut faire du bon travail exactement un
an mais ce monde mais bref il ya veille
avait il parle avec quelqu'un je me sens
impuissant à faire couler le puis envoie
chez l'autre personne en disant ici on
peut te dire au québec quand on peut te
dire on n'est pas censuré président le
premier ministre et un petit tas de
merde qui pullulent vos mii et du coca
et ils entendirent sa chancellerie jean
martineau et devient fou à la télé il
est tellement grand palais comme oméga
plus d'étudiants ce jour même par l
autorise ici ici bien enfin cholet
exactement mais moi je pense que ça
prend des gens comme lui mais il
faudrait que les gens comme lui de
gauche sauf qu'encore russe s'est hissée
c'est juste farceuse lady di fà seul et
d'être trop gros les des fois c'est
comme ça manque de nuance ça fait que ça
rend peu plus intelligent c'est juste
super drôle à regarder mais c'est vrai
mais c'était y'a pas de la regarder une
distanciation puis un deuxième niveau
c'est pas la même chose si tu prends tu
lis qui écrit pour du cash sur fréjus
qui ça fait juste participer à alaves la
séparation en deux temps si tu me
regarder ça avec des nuances plus au
deuxième degré il écrirait autant nous
irait autant de succès c'est jusqu'au
ont brillé avec lui
bon je sais pas où on rirait de lui
l'une c'est juste que le sait ce qui est
triste c'est que des gens qui pensaient
pour du cash puis prennent ça pour des
informations en entier c'est des lettres
d'opinion
c'est ça le prend avec les médias en ce
moment avait un gros problème des médias
c'est que tout le monde donne son
opinion alors que on n'a même pas
l'information pour des gens ne savent
pas ce qu'est ce qui arrive lui avec les
affaires de corruption la town on ne
sait pas le match catherine parce que
c'est marc expliqué c'est expliqué
souvent pour les gens qui ont déjà une
base une acidité lecture elle qui est
fait qu'ils ont regardé les journaux
dans les deux dernières années ils me
soutiennent mais non pitt et sa main pas
été récemment n'ont jamais tant
politiques fax et il m'expliquait de
base un peu mais des fauches comme
jeanne miquel monde se poser de
questions de bosch comme celle
fédérations provinciales
ces tests à peu gênant mais honnêtement
je pense que suivent la politique suive
les choses des médias c'est y pas d une
recherche mettons pour être bien informé
pour aller à la recherche de la bonne
information c'est un travail
d'interaction tout les jours donc les
matins c'est comme c'est comme si vous
mettons occupation double travaillant
qui sut semaine des com pourquoi elle
est pénalisée par le dollar
c'était comme qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et 6 mai avec des affaires plus
complexes
non et c'est sur un conflit complexe il
ya une fois qu'ils aient été engagé pour
jouer de la musique dans une soirée pour
le journal de montréal et québec
ça m'a fait bizarre parce que des
chanteurs français en france est soufflé
le cuivre voir un shoot groenland qui
est un band musique originale fait les
boutiques en france et pij hiquily offre
assez souple est tellement il parlait
mal pour qu'ils pensent qu'ils soient en
anglais
non mais non mr bean québécois mais qui
fait la musique à la madeleine
mais jean thiffault voir un show ce que
tu ailles voir un cas de faillite alors
qu'il en français s'il vous plaît ne
voudrais pas dire manque rien ils vont
pas changer la recette pas s'est écrié
c'est là où c'est vrai faut improviser
toutes les paroles en france que tous
mes tournages à la en direct pour pour
ségo look
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ce qui est
fait mais chut comme c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment ball français après
l'artiste peintre ans au québec bien à
d'autres chantent en anglais c'est quand
même gênant c'est gênant pour tout le
monde à ce tableau b rappaz pas pour moi
bref sa soirée le lot j'ai fini mon
ancêtre mois ses enfants puis j'avais
d'or d'argent de poche et affable je
pars plus tard le horn le prononcer
leurs gammes auxerre que j'entends et je
me retourne puis le hir charteau qui me
travaille bien saisi de chaplin bias je
les prive les mesures logistiques et un
bongo dalphond que j'allais dire ait pu
garder ma place
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'était comme si avant que je passe de
l'humour alors que je fasse seul étage
étaient mes parents sont riches le mais
il y avait quand même décidé de pommes
donner d'argent ils paient pour mes
études mais il fallait quand même que je
travaille les fins de semaine qui va
pouvoir est mangé le loyer manger puis
fois que je travaillais beaucoup les
fans semaine factice comme le ton je me
faisais peut-être 400 pièces par - qui
axé mon loyer coûtait 300 fragments 100
piasses là c'était quand même et
dépenses d allos nemo allez prends des
bières et qui est un peu de nourriture
là dedans je tenais vraiment bien on est
déjà dans le métro que j'ai échappé
m'ont même pièce par terre john isner en
cours et qu'il le prix piqué par tant qu
il voyait les locaux du site
un itinéraire c'est pas que je courais
après itinérant pour avant mon vin
cacher comme messieurs simon vainqueur
ce dimanche aérienne en vie puisque
émoussé me tuer je vais tellement là
j'avais tellement drôle a dit ding fring
pour ça c'est aujourd'hui comme j'espère
qu'ils pensaient que j'ai j'espère qu'il
m'a pas vu le temps dans une émission
fait comme dirait c'est une pièce mais
j'étais vraiment fâché de la rougemare
fait détendue qui arrive politique
change comme c'est georges avait pas de
change le genre seule excuse moi je n'ai
rien dit comment tout un chaurien je
l'aurais bonbon est impec
c'est pas le terrain en a rien à son
talent mais on est un parc un mai puis
on prend un taxi planer je suis comme
fuck même mon portefeuille
j'ai pas mon portefeuille - on retourne
dans le parc on arrive où est-ce qu'on
était un bon portefeuille est pas le
lien monsieur un excellent qu'à ramasser
les canettes qui dit est-ce que c'est
sûr chercher play y avait mon
portefeuille
je fais ce genre oui mais il me redonne
je regardais comme 120 pièces en
portefeuille il y est encore le site de
nice le genre monsieur leur sortie 40
pieds agiles années 40 pièces tout ce
que j'avais ces carnets c'est tellement
les bonnes personnes finalement on était
un petit peu des merdes
on est un peu des merdes c'est là qu'on
est tous égaux
c'est bien de l'avouer de base apprécié
c'est plus c'est plus facile dé changer
pour mieux dire que chez une peste qui
est des fois je filme les faux profils
petit ya tellement d'injustices pieds
tellement de choses qui n'ont pas de
sens a monté les noms des décisions non
éthique comprend à chaque jour sim en ce
moment j'utilise quand même le fait que
je suis vraiment belle menteuse pour
pleine affaire il faut traiter il ya une
fois je sais j'avais oublié mon mon
ordinateur dans mon sac à dos dans un
taxi dargaud pas les taxes d'aéroport à
montréal c'est vraiment compliqué les
rejoint notamment puis là ça faisait une
journée que je sais de rejoindre qui
était quand on est pressé il va tenir
vous portez dans deux jours mais là je
commence à stresser et ses factures j'ai
dit écoutez plus choquant c'est à
pleurer mais je me sens comme alger par
que les gens me jugent soit en est mais
j'ai aujourd'hui j'avais
aucune chance de personnes qui jugent
leurs consommateurs la lys et mystique
ni les têtes dans le passage en cacher
d'autres
si la carte n'est pas si loin
je mets sidibe et en tant que l'affairé
allait tout tout tout mais c'est pas
tout à fait vrai lançant ce qu'elle me
j'avais dépit de la demoiselle et il est
noble mais non j'avais mon hommage aux
docks mari j'avais mon retard inde en
pis si je le prends pas je deviens folle
faculté mais je me sens encore mal ça
fait ça fait trois quatre ans j'ai comme
s'ils venaient mal porté à mon condo
c'est clair que moi et vos idées de tout
était correct s'était rasé les cheveux
ça c'est ma perruche commun comment
s'est passée la cabine pour toi ça drôle
parce que tu es qui misait pour cette
question l'osr ccf parce que tout le
monde le vécu de faire chuter parce que
j'en passe on est encore dedans c'est
l'apport des gens ont commencé à
travailler mais les artistes on est
encore dedans tu sais c'est pas fini
j'ai peu de salles comme sur un choix
soit oui mais j'ai en tout 250 personnes
avec ma meilleure amie plus connu que
moi pour pouvoir vendre des billets pour
voir les bandes les 205 ha ouais c'est
cette enseigne à deux pour pouvoir être
ce qu'elle est bien souvent dit ce qu'il
en reste et ça n'a pas de sens étaient
ses 250 dans une salle de combi chipset
saint-jean moi c'est super ce métier un
peu cette recette et ils ont pour un
prix vraiment dérisoire et été on n'est
pas bien payé je pense que je fais trop
100 piasses ah ouais vous a écrit le
show le en son nom genre cinq minutes
qu'ont écran semble pas pressé c'est
chacun on a fait environ une demi heure
mais j'parle cdd ce qui est arrivé
pendant qu'au budget parle aussi parce
que j'ai fait une psychose et pendant
que j'y fasse et j'ai pris ce but est
déjà bouclée parce que j'ai pris et j'ai
beau petit couac à l'histoire tout le
temps mais c'est simple ça s'est passé
jean le lendemain que la police était
venue pourrait bien mince conjugale
chacune on était comme contient mis dans
l'ambiance est sûr que tout le monde
pensait encore qui m'avait frappé
c'était vrai
malaisie et a pris la blanche mais passé
je les jetais rangers jeu mais péchaient
partage avait déçu par ce n'était comme
poète et physique
c'était plus quel genre juge halluciné
le steak oh mais tu est elle même si ce
texte était l'exercice à ce qu'il est
dans l'ambulance regrettait comme non
mais c'est juste c'est une joie de
petits psychose ou thé parce que mon cas
aller vraiment plus vite le team a fait
le test a comme 180 280 était à bloc
c'est comme si j'avais couru le métier
j'étais juste en train de boire du vin
et prône un jeu beau potes pour garder
mes films fact is a way pillay était
comme un crime en bus et en fait je
pense un petit tour de la ville pour me
calmer la pression de paris et méme hse
gt gt a fait droit la file s'invite
l'acheter sur le qu'il y avait des
cameramen dans le triste et vraiment
psychose rejeté comme vous allez mon
fils quand j'ai su que vous alliez
arraché mon coeur peut le remplacer
est-ce que je devais souvenir vivant et
j'en ai quand même
j'en ai quand même beaucoup j'en ai
apprécié un deux trois heures qui je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé
la presse s est revenue je sais que j'ai
appelé jean ma soeur mettez à une fois
qu'ils m'ont donnée du hâtivement c'est
comme si tu as plus aucune émotion mais
ça continue je préviens quand même je me
disais on se demanda tellement mallet la
fiq juste piété comme ça nous arrive
chaque fin de semaine c'est sûr que
pendant que vivent les gens prenaient
moins drôle parce qu'ils savaient que ça
à l'époque à la l'hôpital toi tu es une
exception que j'ai fait j'ai tellement
grosses marges tout en papotant faisait
n'ont vraiment pas mais j'ai été témoin
y ait de la schizophrénie dans ma
famille et puis honnêtement oui parce
monde y était c'est qu'une fois que
c'est un film c'est plus récurrents que
tu en fasses qui comme deux mois plus
tard j'appelle mon ami un fermier petit
j'y compte l'appeler théorie un peu
billetech com mais le plus drôle la
danse était encore à l'hectare
réveille-toi rosalie c'est comme ça tu
sais des séquelles déjà en avoir pas
mais
il ya eu des séquelles pendant les deux
semaines un prêt de 2 je voyais des
points noirs des fois où et cgc j'ai
regardé vite et je voyais comme des
ombres ou des choses comme cela
je t'ai comme j'ai vraiment eu peur de
rester moi-même passé jeter comme tu
sais si j'ai basé ma carrière sur le
fait que mon passage et fofolle que les
gens viennent en fait c'était comme un
peu j'étais quand même créé mais plus
personne ne croit que c'est un
personnage même à pariscope acquis
toutes les personnes migrantes à part
cela je lis un cas comme ça c'est
jacques servier un jour fox on perd ce
match différemment j'aurais faudrait pas
maintenant même principe mettant louis
xi qu'il était tout à dit joe que vous
êtes à la fage de lui qui se crée ces
gens y arrêter passer par lui qui se
crée cette manne ça c'est ligue 1 grâce
et devant tout le monde le gars que tu
peux plus jamais si c'est ça qu'il ya
beaucoup de nous en faire que c'est ça
ça vient de nous c'est pas bien oui je
suis je le suis piqué comme il ya des
blancs que je fais sur médium cash comme
ils font tout dans maison c'est vrai
mais en même temps je fais jamais d'été
juge à mémé chante ou rien le fait que
ça vole je pense pas que je suis pour de
vrai mais quand je pense que honnêtement
la plupart des humoristes qui fond sur
scène ça ressemble un peu à une
extension à gauche et pascal humoriste
très sablonneux de caunes que la
belgique soit méchant 70 au québec en
plastique et parce qu'au fond de l'eau
mais tombe bien ils vont ils voir venez
pointe capable de genre refaire du mot
maintenant ces gens le vent julien pile
oui 6 km attend chez paulette suis pas
comme moi je pense que non ce n'est pas
peut pas avoir ces actions là c'est
quand même un précieux qui veut payer
pour quelqu'un qui est fait c'est encore
avec vous devrez payer pour un shopping
qui paierait pour un show pour lui-même
et crissements genre d'équipé je suis je
pense pas qu'ils voient ces affaires le
jour en même temps 150 200 personnes je
sais c'est comme les gens qui veulent
savoir a été dans ce sens qu'elle y aura
ce type il passait pas je sais pas en
même temps tu es je sais pas lucic et je
pense pas que il veut sans y vivre pour
il veut pardonner ça me surprendrait il
fait des shows fait des open mic qui dit
shaw genre mais c'est est ce que c'était
mais n'ont cessé mais qui comme pourquoi
julien ou nuit ce qui reviendrait qu'un
des gens qui sont tellement dingue sont
en plus d'être en plus qu'ils sont
drôles sont les envies sont pas des
violeurs il y en eu l'aide des gens
naissent en est des bons animateurs qui
pourrait remplacer eric salvail qu'on
n'a pas encore donné notre chance pour
nous conformer aux coups de coeur mes
clients ne le sait en a plein c'est
juste que je pense que pourquoi on irait
avec quelqu'un que des bibittes piqué le
succès ils montent à tête alors
comprendre des gens qui ont de l'argent
c'est ça c'est que déjà talentueux y en
a tellement beaucoup qui ont pas leur
chance le semis sur ceux des pièces
parce qu'il ya des gens city moi j'ai
c'est que je manque de confiance des
fois la danse qui est ok je pourrais
arriver et puis même pas préparé mon
steak qui peut-être essayer parce qu'il
y en a des humoristes français puis ces
foules bon jeu commun pour une fois
raymond avec maintenant manger choc tout
habache jusqu'à maintenant il faut que
je montre que schumann à chaque fois je
vais pas laisser été fait que je pense
qu'il ya aussi le fait que les gens et
on peut tout en confiance pour prendre
leur place qui leur revient
ouais je pense que les petits pour ces
cas on est pollué et leur place là
prévient je reçois que la place revient
à tout le monde je peux dire que tout le
monde a la même opportunité de prendre
une place choc après le monde mais ton
il ya plein de filles extrêmement
talentueuse qui a réanimé des shows
aussi bien sinon mieux que marie pierre
morel me tombe
mais cette placer leurs jamais fait
aussi bien des mâts
berne répond aussi bien porté voici
bleus maintenant possible maintenons
mais vraiment un critère important pour
animer un shoot et pollet mais ça a
l'air au québec c'est le problème qui
serait morte u-sing une aussi bonne
marche moi bonne question
bonne question puis mais ça c'est
l'autre point puma vent qu'on compte
laisse partir pour prendre toute la
journée mais tantôt c'est à ce que je
pensais personne dans le monde entier
devrait avoir une place qui fait que
d'autres personnes ont peur de critiquer
ou de dénoncer cette personne ne dirige
est quelqu un un statut ou est ce qu'il
ya des gens plus beaux que ces personnes
là qui ont peur des conséquences de se
dénoncer par exemple personne là on
devrait jamais en tant que société élevé
quelqu'un à ce niveau avec ce concept
parce que je peux pas le voir tes mains
même si je suis maintenant connus moi
aussi un homme de 50 ans a dit hey j'ai
super pop freecom que je suis fait est
que mon chien aussi sur ce vote paulo ce
sujet j'ai pas ce concept c gepa un
passant justement les emmène sur l'un
des plateaux le qui fait genre qui
comporte de tout deux dénoncé me tall
qui répare de toi ton influence mais ça
serait ridicule mois il s'emmène 7e
temps mes meilleurs amis moi c'est les
techniciens mes amis quand je sors avec
les gens du plateau ce parle peu des
acteurs parce que si on leur vie puis
souvent les gens comme celui ci voit
beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui tout ce
qu'ils veulent pas nécessairement sortir
et manquant chose ça va être avec les
techniciens ou l'assistante real c'est
ce qui arrive je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est ce qui est ce que tu es
saadi bike et dj ben mutli avec mes amis
de secondaire des milliers d'hommes que
le monde l'industrie
merci à j
son fils est malade parce que c'est des
gens qui étaient choisis avant d'être
connu
c'est moi c'est une des raisons pour que
j'avais tellement peur de devenir
célibataire mais après avoir laissé les
pieds c'est que je m'étais dit mais qui
va voir qui je vais avoir confiance en
qui je peux faire confiance mais peu
connu avant il va j'ai peur que ça soit
pas égal comme un rassembleur que la
personne va pauvres mais mais mais mais
mais comment je suis pour de vrai parce
qu'il est amoureux des personnages de
foleux ou peut-être que justement il va
pas aimer c'est mon memisa forte c'est
tellement du ces pour moi de me dire que
j'allais me trouver quelqu'un souvent
justement quotidien dans cette
république
les gens se dit impatiente et public et
moi il n'était pas question que je fasse
non non non non non non non non gdt une
autre personne un personnalités
publiques qui honnêtement je leur ai pas
dit ici j'ai bon c'était un gars ok mais
mais c'est même pas c'est quoi les
godard qui connut nine inch nails
non mais t'es ggg maintenant eu quelques
je pense j'ai eu une personne connue un
pompier disputer c'est quelqu'un que je
connaissais avant c'est ça on est amis
depuis longtemps qui me connaissaient
avant que soit connue mais jamais ggd tu
es quelqu'un et d'un même que j'ai
rencontré tous les temps a dit moi je
veux un gars qui est peu connu du grand
public
non c'est pas qu'il était si j'arrête
mais c'était c'est sûr c'est plus de 9
la france et c'est plutôt parce qu'ils
étaient comme comment tu fais pour est
apprécié avoir des contacts avec des
gens mais c'est comme ces plats chez
paul mais tu fais beaucoup parlent
beaucoup tard jordan à moi je voulais je
voulais juste quelqu'un avec qui j'étais
bien s'ils n'avaient pas de rapport qui
mettons légaux soit série pas
ton standing j'avais parquet choix une
jauge ans j'avais pas le cas avec des
groupes qu'elle soit une chaude dans la
partie de poker après qu'ils sont comme
il a fait avec une voix de crécelle si
oui avez connu à quai c'est comme moi
j'ai pas eu de one night depuis dix ans
j'ai pas j'ai pas été si je pense que
c'est un respect aussi pour moi mais
aussi c'est quand même c'est pas parce
que si j'avais voulu que chaque dégueu
même même si j'avais cherché j'aurais
pas que ça a été facile mais il faut que
je sois à l'aise lassitude semble pas en
confiance avec personne fakty ggt comme
jadis par chance aux usagers de trouver
quelqu'un qui quittait quitté peu
impressionné par ce maintenant sa patte
en tout et tout le temps non j'ai juste
réfléchissent telle quelle façon va pas
mettre les pieds dans la bouche de ces
garanties ce fait historique pilote en
marque un peu d'art bâton personnage
carte fait historique ce qui est ce que
lui mais ton voyage vous êtes en voyage
en gaspésie placé comme tu fais nestea
niaiseries à être lui le plus calmes
s'est métissé de rapaces ya tellement
mon qui m'écrivent les patients y passe
en tunisie tout le temps je peux pas
supporter le groupe plus chanceux du
monde gris tout le temps j'ai tout
entendu flotte est tellement simple
c'est comme c'est quoi ils veulent une
fifa king plaque payante le tchèque est
essentielle mais ça c'est mon deuxième
degré jean lui dans toc mais même promis
dégraisser dans les cinématiques
champetier bonne humeur royan dont 100 m
ultime eu une fille fucking great à côté
qui va juste à être belge non non si je
vais texter puis je vais te faire rire
les facs témoin je trouve pas qui est
patient et je suis pas chanceux
[Rires]
moi je le crois je me plante d'affairé
trouve drôle c'est moi je trouve drôle
sauf c'est comme en fait on a fait une
vidéo ensemble que j'ai pas encore sorti
parce faut que je monte c'est vraiment
difficile parce que lire tout le temps
je commençais enlève les personnages vos
petits rites est il trop drôle tout le
temps d'un cran pays parce que j'en ai
fait huer et avant avocat marche
c'est la huitième des métiers lui ça le
fait rire tout ça ça m'encourage aussi à
faire plus à faire passer je pourrais
pas sorti avec un dogue qui veut pas
être sur les réseaux sociaux
cc c'est comme ça que je me vante c'est
je montre aux gens que je suis aussi
comme ça t on du personnage mais je suis
même en ville dit jusqu'à pas d'avoir
des délits relation des combats plus
comment on vient avant mais à pas mais
après ce jeu va être deux heures à faire
des blagues et nièces dans le toupet à
chanter des chansons a hérité c'est
correct
c'était 2-2 un petit peu parce que
souvent intelligence puis être nunuche
nous ne nous excite et ça va pas
ensemble mais moi je pense que oui je
pense que je vais me lancer vraiment qui
tendent à la one for christmas is you
toute l'année pourquoi toute l'année
mais c'est folk you tu es folle film
tout cas fait rire en faisant ça c'est
moi si maintenant maintenant j'aime rire
est pas ma job c'est après la huitième
fois chanté white christmas is you le
pays et comme tu dégages d'ailleurs il
faut savoir encore pour qui l'essentiel
est là
le fait est qu on n'est même pas tant on
n'a même pas encore deux heures de chars
de fait sont l'est mais c était
justement réussi que c'est des blagues
c'est je pense que tu sais c'est drôle
devant autant que phares comme un jean
un peu saugrenue même chose comme un qe3
phone 8 6 m
ça te regarde j'écoute pas que ça colle
avec beaucoup de monde qui viennent tu
expliques été joke le bastille catch
pots cassés des jo qui s'est foulé
c'est tellement bizarre mercredi talent
à faire sa vaisselle
enfin la brosse et simone de beauvoir
tout comme de gauche il sait déjà c'est
vraiment comme à gaz que cette consommer
de consommer le mot avec c'est juste le
plus premier des niveaux beaucoup moins
qu'ils consomment pas de bonne humeur le
site où les 10,6 et c'est pourquoi il
faut que je regarde la caméra le même
sort est inquiétant car la job mais des
fois je le fais parce que je comme lyon
peut cacher synge ok je suis même cassé
pas de rire après que me paraît un peu
car je sais c'est que c'est pas vrai je
sais qu'au japon ipap chinoise cgc mais
c'est correct ça veut dire que je le
joue vraiment bien mais tu sais ce
qu'est moi l'idéal ça serait que tout le
monde quatre chemins humeau mais c'est
les gens qui cache pas un temps c'est le
fun parce qu'avec mon public on sait se
fait dans la fonderie de 25% et à salé
qui cachent pas en stock et 25% en sait
plus sur internet m'attendais à payer 35
pièces pour voir quelqu'un je pense que
petit ses billets y en a quand même des
madame des monsieur qui s'en vont
pendant cholet je commençais quoi vous
avez pas mes blagues de ce domicile des
cas pareils kimuak à la saison tous se
retrouvent l'instant seulement mes
petites [ __ ] c'est une fois que j'ai
fait c'était vraiment ce qu'il était
vraiment bête avec moi tout est là et
elle même les madame poule frusquin
millau et son parti il ya tellement il
était même mars le show avait soulevé
son parti ouais j'ai parlé beaucoup
lutté avec mike passé mais qui me dit
souvent qu on se sent maintenant car il
commençait s'il disait moi j'avais le
gréement est un peu naïf je faisais
était des blagues un peu trash sur des
sujets quand même un peu trash puis le
premier one man show j'ai fait là on est
man il y avait tout en quinze vingts
personnes qui partaient pas un homme
jeté comme c'est moi tu sais comme moi
il était comme un cc 2 3 théâtre en
deuxième ou troisième chose arrive recul
les gens savent averti et aussi le fait
que tu aies j'ai fait des émissions pour
enfants puis il ya des parents qui
viennent avec leurs enfants
des toiles mais en même temps il est
vraiment temps que sont comme ils
regardent des choses pires qu'à toi sur
internet j'aime mieux tu regardes
quelque chose de même de un peu
féministe un peu et ouvert d'esprit
plutôt que des personnes justement qui
viole tous ses sens parce que tu est le
premier des gris mat ans l'ado de thé
d'amis metal sous-texte python sous
t'excuser riz féministe le cpie mais
c'est des fois c'est trop
intellectualiser je pense mon humour est
des fois ça peut être juste une joke
fucking c'était bien aussi non maîtrisée
en bout de ligne jeudi l'idée d'un
auteur des valeurs puis les personnes
qui feront transparence fans joe kay
scène docks de viol je suppose qu'on a
fait mais ça y est ça change tout le
temps oui j'en fais maintenant je rentre
c'est ans et 60 piges et quand on a
recommencé d'humour contente surtout de
retrouver mes amis mais plus misé un
défi parce que mes amis de son comme
plus la cote il était comme sur une
liste mais je continue qui gros malaise
en salle mais moi je la trouve trop sept
jours le juge a jaugé 6 parce que les
gens j'ai peur qu'ils me voient pic qui
se souviennent que j'ai fait ce dernier
remet enfin jeu juste comme enlever
l'éléphant dans piège danger c'est que
j'ai fait hier on peut passer à autre
chose mais c'est fade l'humour ne
devrait pas trop de traces ne fait
divers du mot qui flottent et que la
vulgarité qui flotte avec des sujets
sensibles ses soutes vous venez voir
divisés mois ci soit on adore soit on
déteste qui s'est vraiment même payer
des gens qui sont pas capables de
m'avoir pas capable je pense pas qu'il
ya personne qui aime vraiment beaucoup
m'ont eu mon pikine
il déteste ma voix mes tantes et moi je
pense que c'est un tout le bon faut que
tu aimes tout mon personnage je t'aime
tout qu'est ce que je fais puis je sais
que les gens qui me détestent pas chaque
fois je ferai comme il ya aussi des
tests une humoriste parce qu'elle est
fausse tout quel métier sexy puis
ensuite de dieu je trouve qu'il ya comme
des choses plus importantes à et détesté
genre les jeunes de mon opinion sur moi
sur les immenses alors ce qu'ils y ont
aucune opinion sur ce qui se passe un
petit coup tout ce qui se passe dans la
société factice coach peut tout à fait
ne pas consommer tonton du mot c'est
maintenant moi même
j'aime pas dans le moule je peux tout à
fait normaux mettons admettons que je
l'aimais pas j'ai tout à fait le droit
de ne pas l'écouter
oui il ya des humains ce que je sais
qu'ils sont bons geci qui sont bons mais
moi ça me rejoint que c'est correct mais
moi je pense que je suis déjà les
personnes qui est même si je te rejoins
pas c'est pas que je te rejoins peu
cekici maïs bt ont adressé les gens
sentent qu'ils sont forcés à regarder ce
come-back rokocoko les passages vraiment
bon mais non mais c'est ceux ci
s'étaient pas t'es pas obligé mais c'est
juste que moi je sais que je suis
charges de personnel on me déteste ou on
adore puis c'est tout
c'est comme ça mais ça fait que mon
public j'ai l'impression d'avoir des
amis partout j'ai l'impression que les
gens m'aiment vraiment de coopter c'est
j'aime mieux avoir ce public que kate un
humour et ce qui plaît un petit peu tout
le monde mais que je suis pas lui
maurice préfailles personne mais si ça
pis si une pratique thomas avec mike
ward petite dizaine thème outils de test
pilot yamaha tabarnak laïcité si c'est
si c'est quand même mais elle peut
casser plus ben là je m'excuse pour vous
aimez pas casser plus est ajouté qu'en
tant que funny ont cessé bull faisons
n'est pas tant que ceux qui le québec on
parle à la france c'est plus écouter ces
malades ça la francophonie ou au québec
la franco je pense que pacquiao
francophone le plus écouté au moins deux
ans c'est fou c'est incroyable ce avec
de l'humour tu écris ce matc ce que moi
je suis avec michel maintenant ouais
ouais on est semi bursting bientôt là
bas on va pas signer en tête en cette
veille au foot ensemble avec lui puis
laurent segal charles c'est sa nouvelle
adjointe que j'adopte c'est un humain
gérante sur tout mais ça va être des
gens avec qui je vais travailler puis
c'est des gens qui commandent qui
fonctionne ça me ressemble
c'est des gens qui ont une peau et
précis qui peut nécessairement grand
public mais il fait que ça pose partout
que je peux faire qu'est ce qui me plaît
puis faire l'argent avec ça parce que
c'est rome
déjà moi je pense que je suis grand
public quand même là mais j'ai je sais
que mes projets des fois faut que je
fasse un effort sans me tromper dans
voir ça me tente plus de faire un effort
pour être grand public à ce moment le
parce que ça me tente de faire ma foule
puis d'être bizarre que les gens fassent
comme on accepte même je dirais bruno
blanchet tu le faisais c'était accepté
pourquoi peu moins c'est à s'espacer
chine c est ce qui se passe qu'est ma
voix est dégueulasse je sais pas mais je
pense qu'il est temps que les gens
aillent un peu plus l'esprit woerth qui
écoute des choses différentes que le jeu
ou du moins mais j'adore le jeu des
autres traitements ni maurice préféré
jal aime beaucoup et c'est pas mal ma
fille tu tombes et sarah silverman ce
états unis une femme blanche mais je
suis juive
mhamed jadad à chaud c'est vraiment bon
pied c'est vraiment quand j'ai commencé
à faire mon show mon one-man-show
j'étais je prenais pas mon temps pour
mes gars que des fois j'ai été vite
parce que j'ai comme jeanny tellement
que c'était vulgaire mais chez comme je
veux pas froisser personne en dix ans
puis j'ai regardé le show de de l
épidémie et chômeurs puis en année genre
et son genre où la personne alors de me
détester ces watts sperme que j'étais
comme moi sans trop cool et s'est hissé
en feu tellement qu'ils sont tellement
un même sillon tellement accepter le
fait que ça plaît pas à tout le monde
qu'ils font leur steak qui y croient à
cent pour cent blessés légers commence à
être bonnes quand j'ai regardé peut être
moi même qu'y puis-je au mieux de la
sphère au complet plutôt qu'à moitié
fins que celles là j'ai commencé à être
bonnes c'est quand j'ai vu d'autres
familles maurice avoir un peu le même
match que moi
enfin pour jenny de le faire parce que
souvent on me dit j'étais trash mais de
façon plus négative si on dit toi c'est
rageant faut que tu fasses attention au
thé alors quand tu fais comme toi c'est
intelligent pitre achats d'or se pose y
à fond et dans cette émission on est
tous partis
mais je comprends qu'on peut pas tout le
temps parce mais comme le laissait c'est
toutes les fois que j'étais le meilleur
plus fois qu'ils sortent le mieux à la
télé au final les foi qui est un cadre
strict le way peut-être tout fait des
choses qui avaient des codes trop strict
moi j'ai fait des matches c'est tout un
strict raté sauf que quand quand il m'a
dit parents du couple dans mon texte
c'est là que ça devient bon ce que les
gens ont comme étaient habitués qui ont
comme ris tout le long alors que si tu
enlèves tout médoc sont imagés des jokes
éric salvail meute on ne pouvait pas les
foires à tve le riche comme si je vais
la faire en live pia couperont c'est ce
genre de choses qui fait que le public
et dames
c'est le fun c'est le temps elle et
j'avais faite aux roses de quelques
vagues qui est quand même mais qui est
sorti beaucoup seraient internet pas bon
merci mettez là dedans reste est mille
fois plus trash et j'avais des blagues
jawai quand ce super nes c'est bien je
me suis plus jamais jouer 5 et si
j'avais des jobs sur comme le fait qu'on
devient plus grosses qu'en cpns piqué le
feq et moi j'aime les plus grosses parce
que j'ai mangé le piège foule de sang le
petit comme jean c'était vraiment
dégueulasse bulgare puis les gens
étaient crampes et raide mais tu vois
ils l'ont coupé je crois que c'est
qu'avec il coupe mais c'est comme ça
fais avec le public était comme folle
parce qu'après c'est les blagues un peu
moins trash que par des athées les
baisses sont le thé passé quand on coupe
à vanter les gars là c'est difficile des
fois mais les gars leur en fait parce
que plus qu était peu connu plus qu'un
galop c'est difficile parce que les gens
ils veulent voir martin mcl étaient
hagards le bourget n'y en avait pas
trois en deux ans il y avait fait droit
à québec mais là c'était la première
année je faisais légal pour jeunes puis
encore dans les salles c'était quoi mens
tu es c'était quand même des gens qui
venaient pour voir martin map qui était
un peu déçu je pense que le lait ça
s'améliore qu'est ce que tu fais béton
city mettons le lot des quatre victimes
et ont ils des dogues sur son pouls
mettront c'est bon c'est drôle
bush street au charisme en gros les
caisses fermées tant sur soi genre de
quelqu'un qui a meublé sim et en kata
par les dépôts parce que la nana ont de
vrais postiers j'ai pas dis que c'est
positif ou négatif qu'elle avait perdu
jeudi 10 est passé d'une grosse beach à
une grosse beach maigre c'est dans ce
sens que c'est moi je pense que jamais
quand tu parles du poids faut penser à
sa pige relatif moi je veux dire j'ai
pris comme 15 livres le plus choqué je
m'en contente de l'avoir pris parce que
jockey ça me fait jean raimbault culte
est dans ce sens qu il faut justement
métiers de la vente ces gens moi j'ai
des amis qui sont grosses j'ai s'appelle
pas mes amis m'a déjà son gros soupçon
belles soient fiers qu'ils soient
drossés grosse masse devrait pas être
connoté l'été avec mika exactement pitié
c'est vrai qu'elle est perdue pour foutu
peu que j'en parle
non non non elle a perdu du poids puis
est devenu fait qingming et bravo bravo
à sa fille le père qu'elle avait perdue
du poste et joy ou tu me poses ton va
monter s'est plus laissée comme il faut
je pense que if moi je voudrais jamais
blessé quelqu'un on ne ment jamais
jamais blessé quelqu'un je pense me
caille a blessé des gens je me souhaiter
créer puis il ya des fois que j'ai
enlevé la blague que j'ai fait je
m'excuse
trois raisons j'ai réalisé ce qui est
des fois j'ai fait je pense que je
l'enlèverai peu mais je sympathise avec
guti j'avais des blagues sur le fait que
j'avais hâte de faire euthanasier mon
chien c'est clairement une joke les gens
tu es comme on a fait aux nazis nos
chiens sont pensés pour un beau coup
thème qui table i'm the memories of the
children écoutez c'est quelque chose que
j'appartiens j'espère que ça vous a pas
déplu toute la soirée
j'espère que vous allez vous en remettre
mais trop spécifique
ça collait trop spécifique puis j'aime
c'est moi je suis vraiment un classique
grossophobie je regarde beaucoup seul
puisque moi j'ai déjà la famille son
groupe mais t'es gros et qui a cessé ses
groupies jégo ce gros lot était comme un
jeu
je sais que c'est cpo c'est que les gens
sont grosses fautes dans notre société
je le sais je le vois comment et regarde
et cette personne je sais comment que
après 7 e moins d'opportunités parce que
t'es gros fuck faire des blagues de
groupe juste pour rire des grosses comme
non non non ça me semble un peu j'aime
mieux faire des blagues sur le fait que
genre je sais pas moi et fit main se
trouvent tout en gros sous c'est même le
sait même pas drôle parce que tu es
comme peaufine je sais pas je ferai
jamais des blagues méchantes source
mais parler du poids de quelqu'un alors
que c'est flagrant
je peux pas passer à travers que c'est
comme d'un ami d'un ami handicapé tête
il faut que tu fasses un rossa dessus
et en parle peu c'est comme c'est comme
si c'est comme si maintenant on faisant
trop sûrement qu'on parlait pas du fait
que j'ai une voix aiguë uk georges suis
fatigante et ça ça se pourrait pas lui
c'est le fameux des cris des cris ton
ami noir sans adresser le fait qu'ils
montent
oui mais ne fait pas ça fait pas sérieux
c'est pas sa personnalité mais ça fait
partie du lot c'est ça les petits choux
frisés quand même grand et musclé et
puis honnêtement tester moi je m'en
foutais si je voyais pas qu'ils m'ont
jamais tu es noir les dix ans que oui
était noir
mais déjà ce tempo et j'étais à mon amie
stella jones déjà mon homme noir et le
métier comme si j'en avais un blanc mais
quand j'allais présenter à ma famille je
me souviens j'avais dix bâtiments roma
mais personne ne savait même en grand
marat le savait qu'ils étaient non pas
l'avait averti toute la famille tacoma
s'avère-t-il je déconne j'avais un
sketch sur seule puisqu'elle est ma
famille a livré la pop était commenté le
noir il
cc cc comme c'est pas passé c'est ce
silence et non c'est ouais c'est comme
d'études et l'ignorer c'est comme
d'avouer que qu'il faut pas parler c'est
avec ce n'est pas le métier n'était pas
à l'aise et non je serai vraiment juste
trop triste pour toi luis et ben c'est
sûr qu'il ya plein de mombasa c'était
auquel on vit sur toi jane et maxime
actuelle ils ont pas mal un tabac mais
je pense honnêtement que quand tu fais
des blagues sur tout ce qui est
différent que toi tu dois le faire avec
tellement de sensibilité tu dois te
poser des questions puis je pense que
les gens se posent des fois pas cette
question
ou parce que on exagère on ne peut rien
dire mais c'est pas pu rien dire c'est
juste dit là d'une façon kim qui fait
avancer ou odile est une façon originale
tessiture demander à quelqu'un une
transe pour ta blague pour que ta blague
soit bien mise mais bien intelligente
veut demander à quelqu'un qui projette
une personne c'est possible je pense
qu'avec des sujets comme ça tu sais moi
justement les
femmes les femmes battues il était pas
question que je fasse tout seul je
mangeais à une autre fille au triste et
j'ai pas fait tout seul parce que c'est
trop s'était pas la sensibilité dans le
moment puis tu vois c'est sur scène que
ça a décollé ce une personne pendant la
soirée
c'est ta faute que ce ne sont pas bien
entendu mike qui racontait qu'il avait
déjà fait un show pour des femmes
battues puis le sais ce que je vaux
livrer sa blague tout croche le s'est
posté quoi les mots exacts l'améthyste
est comme comment comment son numéro en
disant je peux trop le jeu puisse
exister comme ft gens ne savent pas ce
soir mon césar coly cncc
cephas king grosse il faut king drôle
mais ça prend 10 couillard tabarnak
pourquoi sinon c'est mieux c'est ça
pense pas sur silence ici comme moi je
suis là pour ça exactement c'est même
trop mal aisance non non c'est trop
propre les gens de leur propre légende
le bienfait jeu comme non une faute en
parle justement fait le juste une façon
intelligente seul pour moi c'est super
drôle c'est super intelligent puis c'est
tout le cycle 2 boffard ce mois ci mais
je pense pas qu'il n'ya aucune fille
pendant la soirée
que fait comme il me remémorer quelques
chose si je disais c'est pas assez et
personnels genre à chacune poker mais
j'ai pas en même temps je me bats paris
pour m6 et sat et puis je pense qu'ils
aient à m'amener l'intention pythie le
sous-texte transparaît j'étais petit
mais ton frigo le camp qui fait des jo
qui tire raciale ou à l'erreur
je dis pas tout dit pas oui y aura-t-il
raison puis c'est vrai que les mexicains
sont même temps tu sais que le sous
texte qui rit de tout ça mais la farce
et qu'il faut vraiment faire attention
aux excès c'est que ça soit clair que
c'est ce photo compact avec ton public
démarrer ce qu'ils font c'est un
deuxième degré il était comme moi mais
pourquoi tout ton public c'est déjà la
saison non merci
ces soupes hippies ceci souvent qui est
des fois ça n'est pas interdit nice mari
ce qui fait ma blonde et allemands de
nonne et puis c'est encore acheté une
belle paire de chaussures tu dis ça
c'est juste un gars qui vit à des années
soixante dix le c4
j'essaie d'être plus non mais c'est cet
épi société juste rise up sexy ce
l'espagne aux âmes des grilles le
journal parce que si on regarde les
filles
ils sont tous de grands pays font comme
si vrai que c'est moi que tu es con mais
c'est pas juste et cissé je sais c'est
cette attaque représentativité non dans
le thème de toi c'est poche thébains
plus que ce mobile
c'est bien plus que c'était celle qu'ils
s'acheter une sacoche mais qui
appréciera le fait l affaire de la fob
qui est donc faux lent de la fob qui est
extraordinaire sur plein de choses
puisque ça mérite de parler pas c'est
drôle que tu fais plus qu'aujourd'hui
tâche une grosse sacoche mois maintenant
j'avais des blagues sur fait je
m'achetais une grosse s'accroche mais
j'ai pas vu des choses de restaurant
puis je le mettais d'un essai comme va
plus loin dans ta job je sache une
grosse à cochon cul et comme les filles
à l'uqam le dit vas-y plus loin des
meilleurs c'est hier que j'ai passé à
ces objecteurs podcast d'inde ou de
québec walt qui fait son podcast seul tu
puis les étals je me suis acheté une
nouvelle cameron à la nappe il cherche
comme ma blonde le nom serait possible
mais non c'est une bonne nouvelle pas de
chaussures ben moi j'ai toujours besoin
de renouveau nouvelle ghost dire comme
si ma tante a joke sais je sais c'est
juste pour une bonne job c'est après
cette se rajoute ça donnera pas de
chaussures c'était la fin des gueules
c'est que c'est comme ça va plus loin
que c'est drôle
le oui/non métier sa régie soit c'est
comme tout pour que ce soit vraiment
forcer comme tes blagues de belmonte
blague ça risque mais ça risque aussi si
cette personne n'en ai juste pas aux
bonnes ccpo chargé mais c'est très
possible
ça va rester parole ouais crise ma pole
comme la couleur de notre peau
merci beaucoup d'être venu à mal et ça
me fait plaisir c'est tu sais ce que je
sais pas possible à mon ami jean pendant
une demi heure
et on n'est pas on n'est pas un pas
quasiment vaut le coup d'oeil tout
saboter la star bien aux infiltrés